Who won?
Brian Kalin,
[inaudible] survivor and,
and wearing a sky blue shirt please.
If I call you terrorist survivor,
how much hate do you think I'll get?
It seems like a nice green light for
people to get upset for no reason.
Well,
you know,
I think that everybody wants to be,
if you've not been affected by it,
but you were there,
you want somehow credit.
Like I found myself,
I was 800 feet exactly away from the
blast because I was at the Gotham Comedy
Club Two oh eight w I think west 23rd
and the volume was at one 33.
It's hard for me to think of how big 800
feet is.
So like when I'm on my block,
half a block,
if you look it on,
if you will,
if you actually close,
if you look at on your Google maps,
it's Av block.
And um,
so you were about to go on stage.
I was about to go on stage and I was
with Jimmy Burke,
the national treasure.
That is Jimmy Burke.
I love Jimmy.
Of course you do.
Who doesn't?
And we were talking in the front of the
club.
So I was literally right behind the
front door and the Gotham comedy club,
you have to walk all the way down and go
into the room.
So,
um,
probably about 25 yards.
So I'm literally on the street,
but with the door in front of us and we
just hear about boom.
And that's sickening sound.
Well,
you know,
it's a bomb,
it's not a manhole cover.
You know what I mean?
You just know it's just too long.
I've ever heard a bomb.
It's horrifying.
And it was 800 feet away before that.
You did when you were,
cause I lived in Lebanon.
Right.
So I had,
uh,
in fact I remember going back to
Lebanon,
I can't remember the year,
but they shot a missile.
It was a test fire,
a missile over our head on the beach.
I will never forget this.
It was so loud that we fell down on the
ground.
We were on the beach.
It was so loud.
I don't know if that was because it was
shot over our heads in the sonic boom,
but we fell down.
It May and it was either a shell or
something.
But I remember,
and you don't see it though.
You don't see the,
you know,
the,
the shell because it's going so fast.
But what you do is you hear this
insanely loud noise.
And I remember looking around and
everybody fell down and I fell down.
I,
you know,
you,
um,
it's not even like a fall down.
You are,
it's like you lose your balance and
you're,
you're reaching for something to hold
onto,
but then you go down your hands and
knees.
And it was really strange thing.
So,
um,
and I remember being a kid in Lebanon
and seeing,
uh,
planes,
Bama gas station from the balcony,
and then we had to go downstairs and
sleep in the,
in the garage.
But,
um,
so I,
I heard loud noises as a kid,
very loud noises,
but this,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I'm not a seasoned terrorism expert
here.
Uh,
you know,
a experience her and I don't think
anybody is,
and it certainly wasn't think about
this,
this was a pressure cooker.
This was not a car bomb and that was 800
feet away,
which is how many football fields
explain,
cause it was the same sort of bomb the
used in the Boston marathon bombings
right to go,
right.
Same kind of thing.
And I believe it was hooked up to a cell
phone.
Yeah.
That's how it was activated.
Your cell phone.
Yeah.
And when that thing went off you just
knew it was a mom.
And the crazy that the sickening thing
was before that they said you got four
minutes,
he's coming off in four minutes.
And I,
I ended up,
we were in the front there and Jimmy and
I were talking and I said,
no problem.
And this bomb goes off.
And I said to Jimmy,
I go,
that was a bomb.
And he goes,
yes it was.
And we'd go outside and I see smoke and
it's quiet,
you know,
because there's this pause before the
storm sort of,
and it just,
I saw smoke and you could smell this
sort of um,
like a burning thing,
you know,
it smelled like smoke um,
quickly and then you then instead of
people running towards you in screaming,
they were jogging New Yorkers like ah,
the fuck man,
come on.
That's right.
You know,
and they were jogging.
So your instinct is to go toward the
blast,
you know,
make sure everybody's okay.
But the sixth thing is that when your
instinct is a,
for me,
because I thought there's no way people
aren't injured or killed as well.
I'm fine.
I got to be on stage.
But you know,
this is obviously all encompassing and
do you have any new material you're
working on?
I did and that's why I had to let them
fend for themselves.
I had to fill out.
It's always about our folks.
It's just a bar.
Hey guy here,
good to be here tonight.
Where are you from sir?
You look like Jersey.
What was really bizarre was that we were
running toilet.
I said,
Jim,
we got to go back inside because I was
afraid it was another mom,
right?
Because in Lebanon they used to always
set off an explosion.
The old trick was to have people run
toward another explosion.
Right.
I know that from,
you know,
and my mother used to always say,
be careful of that.
That sounds terrible.
Piece of information to carry around in
your head when you were a child.
It's also important.
I know,
it's horrible.
It's hard because it's so maniacal cause
it,
they're trying to injure people and,
and that's an old technique,
right?
So you,
you create a small explosion,
get people to run toward the bigger
explosion.
There's just something incredibly fucked
up about people's ability to just attack
and kill random people that they don't
know.
Well,
that was playing around out that the
terrorism is,
the idea is to spread fear and get
people to behave differently.
You're not gonna win the war with big
bombs,
but you can get people to change their
routine,
their life,
and the way they think.
And even like I told you when I was in
the Chelsea market five hours before
that,
it was so crowded and it was so,
I just great food people were at a spice
market in clothing and just beautiful
people and I thought to myself,
I'm going to get out of here because
this feels like the place that I would
bomb if I was a terrorist and it was
just a premonition.
I'm sure a lot of people feel that way.
My thinking is different because of the
world we live in,
so they've changed the way my energy og
roughy,
they changed the way I behave the way I
think we know what,
regardless of whether I want to admit
that or not,
I found myself to be nervous in that.
In that,
in that space,
do you think that you would have had
that same feeling anyway of no bomb went
off or do you really think that there
was a premonition or one of those things
where you sort of connect to feeling
like,
I don't believe in premonitions.
I mean,
maybe I do if you can read signals and
stuff,
but that wasn't the case for me.
I just said I have an act of
imagination.
My take on that kind of stuff is maybe,
you know,
it's right.
I don't want say,
I don't know,
because there's not a goddamn way to
measure it.
There's no,
but there are weird moments where people
have weird thoughts,
but just wondering if you really,
yes.
Well,
the answer is there.
There,
there are two books that were,
had been,
this has been studied and thinking fast
and slow by Daniel Kahneman.
He won a Nobel Prize for economics and
behavioral economics.
And then,
uh,
in Malcolm Gladwell's book blink there
are,
and for that matter,
Josh Waitzkin,
his book,
the art of learning,
all three great books that I recommend
to everybody because there are signals a
human being,
and soldiers talk about this when
they've experienced a lot of IED,
they get very good when their life
depends on it at reading signals,
the stillness in the air behavior that
they can't explain.
But why are those people acting a little
bit differently?
Why are the women not out?
Why can't I see any women out?
Why is it just men?
Why are the windows being shut right
now?
They pick up on all these little signals
and in blink and in thinking fast and
slow,
there are,
there are things we pick up on very
quickly.
We just have pattern recognition.
There are other things that take a long
time to think about,
right?
So a math problem like 48 times,
you know,
36 would take a long time.
It's a slow process and you can't do a
lot else when you're doing that.
But you can recognize if somebody is
running at you screaming with their eyes
open and their hands up that they're
probably going to do something physical
to you or something.
We registered these in very quickly.
The same goes for,
you know,
any kind of a situation.
Probably when something's about to
happen,
there may be a change in behavior.
There may be,
uh,
this doesn't look right.
Why does that road,
why is that bump in that road that
wasn't there last time?
Those kinds of things that soldiers talk
about.
So for me,
I think this was just simply the idea
that I was closed in,
everything was really great and I felt
like I have coffee running to my body.
I'm,
I'm on a caffeine high,
I did my yoga,
I feel good.
This is too good to be true.
I'm going to turn around in case a bomb
goes off and blows my head off that,
that's more just paranoia.
But in this case,
after the bomb,
I ran and I said to Jimmy,
I said,
come back inside,
come back inside.
That could be a second bomb.
And he said,
yeah,
you're right.
And so we ran back inside and they go
Juran and now I go,
but there was a bomb and they'd go,
what?
And I said,
the a bomb went off and they go,
well,
you know that the full house sold that
house.
So I run on stage and the real worry was
my cousins were coming to see the show
and I thought that they were,
you know,
right there.
So that's what I,
so I had to kind of get myself together
and do stand up and my heart was beating
fast,
but it was more depression.
It wasn't,
it was less than fear than more
depression at the world.
We live in that sound.
So then I did stand up and in halfway
through or three quarters of the way
through an off duty cop who works there
walked on stage cause he stopped the,
the,
the soldiers that came in with the
machine guns.
He said,
let me get him off stage.
Don't,
don't raid the comedy club please.
And Hope Bizarre.
Yeah.
So he walks on,
literally walks on and I turned and I
went,
oh no.
I just said,
Cause I was confirmed.
I knew something was bad,
you know.
And he said he took the mic out of my
hand.
He said,
sorry folks,
we have to get you out of here.
And then we left.
It was just depressing,
man.
Wow.
I'm not a terrorism survivor,
but I witnessed on blue.
What did that feel like going on stage
right after you knew that a bomb went
off 800 feet away.
You know,
I asked Jimmy who was there and I said,
well did it seem like I was nervous?
He said,
nope,
you just went right into pro mode.
You know,
I've been doing it so long and I,
and I,
I,
it was a full house and I just said,
you got to get it together.
Wow.
I think,
I think anybody who's been doing standup
the way as long as I have or you have,
I,
you know,
we,
we'd figure our way through.
You know,
I probably was speaking faster.
I could feel my heart beating,
but it was also just,
it's terrifying man.
When you,
when,
when it's that real,
you know,
when,
when you think about the fact that
people are walking through their lives,
life is hard,
right?
Like just accomplishing shit.
Keeping yourself on the straight and
narrow flossing,
fucking working out,
going for your dreams anymore.
It was like a study.
Oh I heard about that.
You know,
this is flossing is bullshit.
Good.
Cause I use a toothpick cause I'm a man.
Good for you.
And then,
and then something,
the random can happen and all those
plans go out the fucking window.
Yeah.
That's the strangest aspect of it,
isn't it?
The randomness of it.
But all of a sudden these moments
unexpected or introduced into the world
and they change everything,
you know?
And we only see our,
our side of it.
Obviously this is happening all over the
world to varying degrees.
We're just so insulated from this kind
of stuff that when a random act like
this does happen,
it's so shocking.
But if this was in,
you know,
the worst aspects are the worst parts of
the world,
they're probably experiencing these
kinds of things.
How to daily all the time.
And not only that,
if you look at the great artistic
expressions,
like look at Picasso and take a look at
what he lived through.
Look at the world that those people live
to.
Giacometti who,
you know,
he made these sculptures of,
um,
it looks like people who have been
through a holocaust to it,
to a nuclear holocaust,
they were very,
very,
you know,
political commitment in the 20th
century.
It wasn't something you could not have.
Right.
And,
and they witnessed world wars and
nuclear weaponry and all kinds of
things.
Probably Influenza that killed 20
million people worldwide,
all kinds of stuff.
And they let it inform their,
their artistic expression informed their
behavior.
Look,
you've talked to a world war two
veterans.
I've talked to old guys.
I said,
what was it like when you came back?
They said,
you're just more serious and there's
more of an urgency to get things done.
You don't have as much time.
Don't make sense.
Yeah.
And,
and so the idea is to whatever happens,
whatever happens,
you can react in a way that it in a form
of paralysis or you can allow it to kind
of get you to think,
I don't know,
a lot of,
and
it's such a catch 22 in many ways
because our society has never been
safer.
It's never been easier to exist in the
west,
at least in America.
It's never been easier,
you know?
I mean,
we have more healthcare,
we have more access to information.
There's less violent crime,
there's less.
Everything.
Cars are safer.
There's so much.
But because of that,
every little thing gets blown out of
proportion.
That's right.
Things like this is horrible as they are
are a wakeup call.
I remember in nine 11 right after nine
11 like within the next year,
we filmed fear factor in Manhattan and
everyone was so nice.
Everyone was so nice.
It was really fascinating.
It's like everyone was happy and they
were so nice and they were so happy when
they saw cops and firemen,
firemen and cops were fucking
superheroes for like a good solid two
years like they should be.
If people had perspective like,
Hey,
there's a bunch of people that are there
to save your life,
you should be so thankful and happy that
there as opposed to,
oh my God,
I saw that guy that hits the ball with a
stick.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
I was sweating when I was near him.
There were fucking crazy man.
We are crazy and as soft as things get,
when they get softer things get more and
more added.
A perspective like that Matt Leblanc
story that we're talking about before
the podcast folks,
this is like the height.
This is the height of the craziness of
people getting upset at fucking nothing.
I'm gonna give you the height right now.
Re pull that,
pull that up.
Cause this is,
this is so classic example of people who
lose perspective on what really matters.
They just,
they don't have any real existential
threats out there to their own lives and
their way of life.
So they have to find an enemy.
And this is a classic example of being
outraged at something you shouldn't be
outraged by.
Here's the article.
It says Matt Leblanc was disgusting on
the Emmy's red carpet and can leave
showbiz now.
Now in this person's defense,
the author,
I have no idea if that is what she
actually wrote as her actual title
because I know that editors change
things and you know,
they try to make things more
inflammatory and if it's so much easier
to make something more inflammatory when
it's,
you're an editor and you take someone's
work and you add some stuff to it,
you add a title to it.
Who knows if that's what happened.
Just to,
just to clarify,
because that is a possibility.
So this is what he says.
Um,
they're talking to,
he's on the red carpet with a,
the,
the woman from game of thrones,
Emilia Clarke,
who plays a Khaleesi,
right?
Yeah.
And she says he's objectifying women,
but let me,
he's got disgusting characteristics.
Let's just say his,
his,
his actual statement,
he goes,
I saw the first season,
then kind of fell out of touch with it.
And I guess that's when she started
getting naked.
So I need to catch up.
That's it.
Yes.
All he said.
Yeah.
So I would say in a,
that's all he
said.
And he is a comedic actor.
He's doing an interview.
He's trying to be funny.
That's right.
He's just being silly.
I mean,
I think Dan was like the nicest,
most polite way of being pervy I've ever
read.
But she called him,
she called him and he shares some of his
characters.
Disgusting,
disgusting characteristics like
objectifying women.
So that's,
that's,
that's why,
what is her name,
the woman who said that?
It's unbelievable.
So her name is,
uh,
Lauren holter.
I wonder really with people like this,
you're right.
I wonder what their historical
perspective is on things.
We've come a long fucking way and I
mean,
in women's rights and you know,
Obama had a great speech that I listened
to listen to it.
[inaudible] 2016 he gave it to Howard
College,
which is a black college.
And yes,
yes,
there are,
there are race issues by Obama said,
yeah,
I'm going to say some controversial
things were all way better off.
And Oh,
by the way,
uh,
so our race relations when I graduated
in 1983,
it was a lot harder and there are more
opportunities.
And to not give the that credit,
and then I'm give to not suggest that we
are better off.
It doesn't mean there doesn't mean you
get complacent and it doesn't mean there
isn't work to do,
but please understand that there we have
come a long way.
And to not give credit for that.
It's not give credit to the foot
soldiers that did all that work from
1983 until now,
many of whom were people of color.
So when you say,
you know,
it's things that never been worse,
you're wrong.
You don't have historical perspective.
And I'll give you another perspective
that New York Times had this interesting
editorial and whether this is true or
not,
but if you define war as countries going
to war over territory,
resources with national armies,
five out of six people on this globe are
not living in countries at war.
One in six are in conflict,
uh,
war torn areas.
And those,
those areas go from Nigeria to Pakistan.
Now,
uh,
that's,
that is a large part of the globe,
primarily in Middle East,
primarily the Muslim world.
That area is in strife and at war and
there's a lot of tragedy.
But please keep in mind,
that's one in six people in the globe,
Latin America in the 70s and the 80s,
our lifetime,
we're military dictatorships.
Nicaragua was a communistic t and not
even a communist dictator,
but it was a communist country where
there was a huge insurgency,
huge wars being fought,
insurgencies,
lots of death.
Uh,
no democracy whatsoever.
Latin America has a lot of problems,
but let me tell you,
at least they are run by civilian
governments as corrupted as they may be.
That's big progress.
So you've got to kind of measure,
you've got to measure where progress has
been made,
give it credit and,
and then don't let that make you
complacent because there's always work
to do.
But at least give it credit.
I completely agree with you,
but I think you're giving her statement
way too much credit.
I agree.
I think what she's doing brought in
Pakistan and Nigeria falls.
I mean,
I think she's probably laughing that
were ridiculous.
We're studying
what's obviously like a clickbait
bullshit.
Yeah,
you're right.
I mean it's,
She's looking to be outrage.
She's got to write a story.
This is a story here.
I got something here.
Let's run with it.
Yeah.
I mean that's what a lot of what's going
on with these internet sort of website
stories.
That's a lot of it is just,
I just took the bait at night.
Well,
there's a lot of fake ones.
I mean,
you've seen fake ones and it just
completely fake to some make up a story.
They made up a story about,
um,
me disarming some person at the comedy
store,
some person with a gun,
and I got a text from a buddy of mine
who's a cop and he's like,
did you,
did you take out a,
uh,
you know,
God,
congratulations.
That's very difficult to do.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
And people ask me if you had actually
killed a mountain lion with your bare
hand.
And I was like,
absolutely.
How much money do you think they could
make for those fixed stories?
I mean,
what do they,
is it real money in that a click,
a couple hundred bucks or something?
Probably not.
I'm not under probably just a way of
getting attention,
but there's,
there used to be,
used to be like the onion,
the onion would say shit.
That was,
you would read the headline and go,
ah,
and then you would read what you knew to
be satire.
You knew parrot,
you knew that would be fake was funny.
It was absurd.
Now there's a bunch of websites that
have taken with them.
They'd done and made it way less obvious
that they're trying to be funny.
Yeah.
It's just weird.
But that,
but I do think that we live in a time
and there's probably kind of a blow back
now.
It's interesting,
but we do live in a time where people
are just way too sensitive and it's,
and it's certain loud mouths in the
media.
I mean,
when Alec Baldwin wrote an article
saying,
I think I quit and it was like he was
leaving Hollywood.
He,
no,
he's done so much for gay rights and
he's always been a really liberal guy.
But he called the guy a cock sucker
because the guy ended up taking pictures
of him and his wife and then you know,
and I guess they consider that to be
homophobic and he got just lambasted by,
you know,
fucking,
the sort of lunatic fringe.
But it was really bad and it hurt his
feelings and he was like,
you guys are pointing your guns at that
wrong enemy.
I'm not your enemy,
I'm your advocate.
But you're so you're so caught up on
your power trip.
It's what happens to any group,
any like Greenpeace is a good example.
The guy used to be part of Greenpeace
said,
look,
we've got a lot of stuff done.
But there were a lot of people that
weren't willing to let it go because,
and they needed a new closet in new
costs cause they were addicted to the
power.
It wasn't so much about saving the
whales anymore.
It was about the fact that they,
they had a sense of identity and they
had power and they could really shake
things up and cause good people who were
involved in doing good work to have to
stop and go,
Huh,
why?
Well that's what a lot of people are
doing by writing blogs,
whether they realize it or not,
that's what they're doing.
You're trying to claim your own space by
jumping in and trying to get a reaction.
And in that case that Matt Leblanc cake
case,
it's one of the most obvious blatant in
bizarre what like if that really,
that captivates a moment of your time
other than laughing or not laughing at
that moment.
Right.
First of all,
let's break down what he's saying he
needs to catch up because uh,
she started getting naked.
Are we supposed to pretend that we don't
like looking at her naked?
Is that is so a man standing next to a
woman who has been paid to be naked on
television show?
Was he supposed to pretend that that's
not an enjoyable thing to look at?
How I get,
I get confused because if a woman is
standing next to a man and says the
exact same thing,
I guarantee you no one gives a fuck
course.
And everyone might laugh if amy Schumer
said that next to a Brad Pitt,
what if he said this?
What if he had said,
I'm not going to watch it?
Uh,
uh,
she takes her clothes off and it
objectifies women and I,
and I refuse to actually,
I'm afraid I may enjoy it if I watch it.
And so out of respect for her and her
privacy,
even though she's taking off her clothes
and,
and it's an artistic expression and a
great TV show,
I don't approve because I don't think
women should take their clothes off now.
Now you're a pure,
now you're puritanical.
Do you really want to live in a world
like that?
Because I'll tell you something.
There are a lot of countries,
a lot of countries like for example,
Saudi Arabia and a lot of other
countries that are,
you know,
not,
not the,
not at the forefront of women's rights
that would,
uh,
we'd be outraged and wouldn't let you
see that and would censor that.
So what are we talking about here?
What are we talking about?
We're talking about a joke that
objectifies women.
Have you seen that Cosmo,
the two comparisons of the cosmo covers
one of them,
it says why men who objectify women are
the effing worst.
And then in the next one,
it's all about men's packages in
bikinis.
Really.
Just their cocks in became,
it's great.
I mean,
it is literally just an object.
It's not even a full person could just
focusing on Cox in Bikinis,
same magazine.
But what,
what do you mean by objectify women?
What does that mean?
It doesn't mean anything.
I think women that are naked or
beautiful,
well objectifying,
treating them as objects instead of
people.
Well,
I'm not trying to start a relationship
with her.
I'm trying to look at her naked in
dragon movie.
Yeah.
You know,
she rides dragons around,
right?
It's a dragon lady.
She's the mother,
right?
Yeah.
Mother of dragons.
I'm trying to look at her naked.
Is that okay?
If you don't want me to look at her
naked,
how about you don't show it is,
oh look at that wealth by the way.
36 silver Olympic bulges that deserve
gold and it's all just dicks.
Just hogs in Bikini was in men's
kidneys.
This is awful.
This is so silly.
And they're looking at just raised.
But the other one confirmed dot.
Dot.
Men who objectify women are effing
horrible.
So it's a woman looking straight at the
camera.
I like,
she's like,
girl,
you know it's true.
I'm going to fucking tell you.
And you know,
and the other girls got to be like,
fuck yeah,
them pieces of shit men.
And look at the guy in the background.
They couldn't have picked a douchey or
looking guy.
He looks,
I'm sure pissed Aspen.
And by the way,
he's got his,
he's so beaten down.
He's got a sheet over his head.
The poor guy pop out.
He's got his clothes on.
So does she,
and they were under the covers.
This is a disaster of a relationship.
It has nothing to
do with the men objectifying women.
You if he objectifies women,
how the fuck did he trick you to the
point where you're both with no clothes
on or with clothes on under the covers.
What is going on here?
What cc you're making poor choices as
well.
Yeah,
I see.
When I think about objectifying women,
I think about this like I think about,
uh,
you know,
cause I think it's great.
I've been to strip clubs,
I've,
I've paid money to watch girls,
uh,
take their clothes off.
Maybe I've even been moaning to him.
Essentially girls,
I dunno Joe,
there's a lot of people are listening
and I have children.
Here's the point.
When I was younger.
Um,
but I think when I think of objectifying
women,
yeah.
Cause me,
I'm,
I'm a,
you can call me a feminist in terms of
like,
if you can do the job,
I don't give a fuck once you look like,
you know,
um,
but for me,
objectifying women I suppose would be,
well,
she's got a,
she's just good for banging.
She's,
that's just three holes or two holes
depending on what you're into.
Treating them as a nonperson.
Yeah.
And then,
and then of course,
uh,
dialing them up and not really allowing
them to realize their potential.
Maybe supporting policies or thoughts
that don't sort of,
um,
allowing them to do that.
I can understand how women have suffered
from that and continue to,
I get it,
you know,
Russia and they talk about what it's
like to be a woman in Russia.
And I,
I know that there are issues like that,
but come on,
man,
humor is really important in including
humor that objectifies women.
It's fucking important.
It's,
it just makes it less of an issue.
I think
it really does.
Well,
it completely depends upon what is the
humor,
what is the joke,
what is the context?
It's,
there's a long,
broad range of of variables.
When we talked about comedy material and
that quote Unquote objectifies women,
but that a flippant off the cuff
humorous remark at some sort of a
ridiculous little red carpet interview
thing.
You know those things,
those things are ridiculous.
The will,
you have to apologize.
Oh God,
I hope he doesn't.
I hope he doesn't,
but he works.
He's a working actor.
He's not comedian.
See working actors are always subject to
the will of people that are out there
that are looking to hire people.
You're always going to have to audition.
You're always going to have to get
approved.
When Matt Leblanc is up for things is
probably a few other guys that are like
really high profile guys that are up for
it too.
And if one of them is involved in some
sort of scandal or some,
someone thinks that they're objectifying
women and their effing horrible,
they should leave show business if that
catches any momentum,
this horrible things that people have
done right.
Like admittedly horrible that they
themselves just fell apart like Kramer.
Right.
Perfect example.
That was a career killer that killed
that guy.
Yup.
Like from then on he is not the same
guy.
No,
there's does just that was a a monster
whopper awful thing that went down
so which I'm more sympathetic to because
if you made that mistake,
if you did that,
you better be ready for the
consequences.
That was offensive.
Right?
I mean I think he had an outburst.
He had a moment but you,
you can't have,
it's like saying I had an a moment and I
punched that guy in the face,
then stomped him in the head and he
can't walk the same.
Everybody has moments where you want to
do certain things but you got to pay the
price for that.
I also think,
and this is a complete a rumor,
but this is what I had heard was that
cocaine was involved.
Now if that's true,
it may not have been if it,
if it wasn't,
I apologize.
Legal Shit out of the way.
If cocaine was involved,
people that are on coke get ridiculously
confident and they say ridiculous shit.
That just does not jive with everyone
around them because the other people
around them aren't on coke.
They're not on coke in,
especially if you're on coke,
it seems like you're all about yourself.
It seems like it becomes a very sort of
a selfish,
isolated little sort of environment
protecting,
you
know,
wasn't sure.
Certainly that's what I'm saying,
but I'm saying he thought he could get
away with that.
He thought he could talk like that and
who knows what they had said to him.
I don't know.
You know,
the whole thing was him getting
frustrated.
The fact that he's really just not a
very good comic and he was getting
heckled and we're saying,
you're not funny.
This isn't funny.
Yeah.
The,
when someone tells you you're not funny.
And I've had it happened to me,
I've had someone tell me,
oh not funny when I was bombing and you
agree with them,
it's like there's nothing you can do.
You agree with them.
And so I think with Kramer was trying to
do is hurt their feelings and that was
how he thought he could hurt their
feelings.
I'm sure.
I don't think that he's,
I don't think he's a racist.
He's like,
I,
I if you said to cram,
if you think that because people have
more melanin in their skin,
they should be,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
I don't think that's how he thinks.
I don't think he's that dumb.
And I don't think,
but again,
again that that's hey,
that's like the Mel Gibson thing to look
when you get drunk or you're on blow or
whatever.
If you then decide that the Jews are the
reason everything sucks and you shout
shouting that to a Jewish cop,
uh,
or,
or that you know,
you hope your girl gets,
you know,
has had,
is forced to have sex with in the 19
black theaters.
But using the n word.
I don't,
I've never look,
I,
you know,
I've never really had those kinds of out
that this is kind of me man.
It's also kind of like it's called.
So it's also,
what's the other word?
Um,
it's blatantly fucking racist page.
Well,
you live in a world where you just can't
say that Shit,
man.
It's the words of a crazy person.
Yes.
Because as times goes on and you become
older and you meet more people,
you realize there are a bunch of
variables when it comes to people's
behavior and what they do.
But those variables are usually based on
culture,
on economics,
on the society that they live in,
the family they grew up with.
And you're going to meet people that
you love,
that fill all of the blanks.
Asian,
Caucasian,
European.
You're going to meet people you love
that are all in there because they're
just extraordinary people and you're
going to meet people that are fucking
cunts and they're going to be in all
those things too.
There's just no way around that folks.
And if you start siding on one gender or
one race or one patch of dirt,
your fucking missing the whole thing.
The whole thing is we are globally one
super organism that does not have the
ability yet to communicate in real time
across the board with each other in a,
in an incredibly honest way.
We can't really do that yet.
You could speak a certain amount of
languages if you're a fucking super
wizard and you can figure your way
through a lot of countries if you know
their cultures,
but they're not necessarily gonna
understand ours unless they can read our
fucking minds.
We all speak to any different languages.
We live in too many different places.
We're so used to one way of life that
anything,
any variations,
any breakups,
and then one way of life throws
everything into a fucking tizzy and no
one knows what to do about it.
Whereas the rest of the world is
experiencing all sorts of different
strife.
I was watching this show the other day
called uncharted and this guy was a,
I've taught,
I've talked about this before,
but it's just,
it was so harsh to watch.
He,
his name's Jim shockey and he goes to
all these really remote villages and
stays with the local people.
And in this one they were getting killed
by crocodiles.
Oh yeah.
These people are going to the river and
every time they would go to the river,
they would have to set up these nets and
the crocodiles,
they target people.
So when a crocodile starts targeting
people,
they have to go and shoot it.
And everyone in the village was fucked
up,
man.
Everyone in the village was losing his
missing him blends three fucking third
or fourth person at a giant bite taken
out of them.
It's crazy.
And they just live right next to this
river and they survive off that river.
Did they live in these little huts and
shit and he's thinking like you are
complaining about the wispy joke might
not have been the best joke,
but I would have laughed if I was there.
Sure.
If he said that,
I would have shot that with silly and
the fact that we're trying to pretend
that this is some sort of an outrage and
that this person she defending,
who is she trying to defend here?
What is she trying to do it that.
That's the other thing.
It's more about her though situation.
Well,
it's recreational outrage.
It's a thing that people are doing.
It's a thing that people are,
that's great.
That's,
I've never heard that.
I love that expression.
It's recreational outrage.
Recreational outreach.
They have decided to be out.
If your outrage at that,
that is really filling up your time like
I am going to fuck this terrorist
attack.
I am not as Lama phobic.
I am not writing about the terrorist
attack.
I am going to write about Matt Leblanc
being a piece of shit.
Yeah,
he should leave the now he's the
problem.
He's the,
he's the problem.
It wasn't a bomb went off.
I went and well Matt Leblanc is sexist.
Here's the thing.
Stop saying the worst.
Everybody.
Everybody stopped saying the worst
because that is like that.
There's no better symbol of our
sheltered time than people saying the
worst.
I was reading this account of how
certain people were tortured with these
to skin them alive with sea shells.
They would take like an oyster shell and
they would skin these people alive.
They would tie them down and skin them
alive with oyster shell.
It's got to feel good.
Yeah,
so that's the worst.
Yeah.
That would be the worst.
That's the worst.
Not I'm with you on that.
I would have to say that that would be
the worst.
It's the worst.
I think a good way.
You know another,
here's a question really is there's this
tendency that we all have,
right?
So when this guy,
you find this guy who fucking bomb
people in Chelsea and you,
you,
you want him to die or you want him to
go to jail forever and I hope he suffers
and all that.
The the,
the way to look.
There's another way to look at things
which might be not only more helpful,
but might lead us to better solutions.
And I don't know if this is true,
but that's a good way to look at human
beings.
We all have the same hardware.
There's been a lot of science,
a lot of work on this.
You know,
we have a lot of,
we,
we basically have the same hardware.
Um,
if you look at the way human beings are,
if you draw through lines,
even with cultures that have been not
very,
not exposed to a lot,
but there's been a lot of work done on,
regardless if you're a highlander in
Papa New Guinea or you're northern
European,
you know,
senator have,
a member of government and you've been
exposed to a lot.
We recognize certain things.
Um,
most cultures have a tradition of
humorous in salts.
Uh,
human beings.
It's seems innately can tell the
difference between joy and discussed.
Um,
and happy and sad.
We have,
we essentially have the same hardware.
It's why you can't really look at
someone's skin or if someone's racial
features and you know,
realize what they're capable of.
Well,
what could that guy be a scientist?
he's black.
He couldn't be because there aren't a
lot of stuff.
You just can't do that.
And we all know that.
So really what it is is software
culture.
What you have been exposed to,
your belief system,
what you've been told is true.
What you've been told is right.
What you've been told is good versus
evil.
That is,
uh,
essentially what motivates people to do
good and bad things.
You know,
Freud said that man goes to war because
he hates people well or he,
that he has a lot of aggression,
hatred.
Well,
there are a lot of other scholars would
say,
maybe not.
In fact,
men don't go to war out of hatred.
They go to war out of love.
They go to war because they love the
country.
They are defending.
They go to war under symbols and
propaganda.
They go to war under and for an idea
that they are defending because men and
countries define themselves along the
lines along certain lines that they are.
If you think about any man,
we all have a line and we all have a
line that we're willing to,
at least in our mind,
that we're willing to defend with our
lives.
Probably at the front door of our house
if somebody coming in and try to get to
our kids,
but certainly our country and this
country is very nationalistic.
If you start talking about,
you know,
um,
you Americans get very nationalistic,
have you started making,
you know,
making fun of the flag?
There it is.
Look at that flag.
Hey,
it's Dan.
Hey.
So it's better sometimes to think to
yourself,
I wonder what kind of software went into
this,
this guy's head,
this guy who just did the bombings in
New York?
What kind of software was he exposed to?
Obviously it wasn't good software and it
might make us,
I don't know if compassion is the word,
but it might make us more understanding.
And so if you understand your enemy or
the enemy,
which may not be people,
but rather an ideology,
maybe that's the best way to then fight
it.
I always try to look at perspective as
like a large creation that's made with
little tiny lego blocks.
And with every life experience that I
have,
I try to add a few more lego blocks and
they might not change me radically.
But over time,
those lego blocks can build and become a
significant structure.
Something that you could see and look at
and measure.
That's cool.
And every time one of these things
happens,
I always try to think of a,
there's perspective that I had when,
uh,
when my kids start walking and talking
to them and seeing them go from coming
out of their mother's body to being a
little person I could talk to,
I started realizing,
okay,
it seems like my thought was always that
people were static,
that I meet,
you know,
Mike McGee and he's 32 years old.
Hey Mike,
how are ya?
Nice to meet you.
This is Mike McKee.
He's 32.
Mike was a baby at one point in time.
It came out of his mother's body and
help us a little thing like all of us
did.
And then through all sorts of weirdness,
life experiences that are completely
random and people that probably were
totally unqualified teaching them things
and growing up with a bunch of other
kids that were similar in a lot of ways,
similarly getting fucked up by their
parents and their upbringing and their
religion and their,
uh,
a million different variables.
Right?
And then there's all these alpha
chimpanzee jockeying positional things
that go on in these relationships with
kids and kids bully kids.
And sometimes those kids that are
bullied,
it ruins them for the rest of their life
and they just,
they're devastated for like literally to
the grave from some shit that happened
when they were 10.
So we're,
we're subject to so many different
variables and so many different points
of data entry.
Like data can come at us in so many
different ways was his physical data,
whether it's just reading the news and
trying to understand like why would
someone go to a nightclub in Orlando and
just start shooting gay people?
Why would someone drive a truck in,
in France and just drive over those
people?
Why would someone do that?
I'm like,
what?
What is that was a baby at one point in
time,
something has led to that and we have to
look at all the things that influence
us,
all of them,
whether it's behavioral things,
whether it's things that are were beaten
into you by just life's hard lessons.
And then the big one that nobody wants
to discuss.
Ideologies.
Yeah,
call them whatever you want.
You want to call them religions,
you want to call them cults,
calm,
whatever you want.
But at the bottom line is they're
incredibly structured patterns of
behavior that you are forced to follow.
That can be real dangerous if people
don't follow them.
And nobody wants to admit that.
Nobody wants to admit that when you
leave this pattern of behavior,
you're supposed to be killed.
No one wants admitted.
If you vary from this pattern of
behavior and do no one any harm like
homosexuals,
you're,
you're to be killed.
I mean,
there's some really,
and you know,
oh,
this is,
this Islamophobia on this show has got
to stop.
I'm scared of rats,
scared a lot of dogs.
So let me just tell you what,
I'm scared of.
Scare a lot of people.
I'm scared of questions.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of,
uh,
ex cons.
I'm scared of pis and vans driving
around.
I was scared of clowns.
It's kind of a lot of shit.
So this,
this idea of being,
having a phobia over a,
you know,
a particular ideology or I'm fuck me
over pattern recognition to you.
You,
you,
you can pattern,
right?
Will you stay alive by being able to
recognize patterns?
Yeah.
And it's the,
but the important aspect of it is,
and this is always what's important,
is that most people that are practicing
that on hurting anybody,
right?
Most people that are practicing Muslims
aren't hurting anybody because there's
so many of them.
If they were,
if there was a war between Muslims and
Christians and would just spilling out
into the streets every day,
Jesus Christ would be a blood bath
everywhere,
every one in a million,
300 million Muslims,
I think it would be insane.
So the,
the,
the problem is not a particular ideology
in much in as much as it's a particular
strain of the ideology,
whether it's a Christian that goes to an
abortion clinic with a fucking high
powered rifle and starts taking people
out,
whatever it is.
Somebody who has the thinks they have
the truth with a capital t,
which is called a fundamentalist.
And we're all fundamentalists.
You know,
we all have aspects of our personalities
and our belief systems that are
fundamentalists.
If you asked me about sugar,
I'll wax poetic.
I'll tell you all about the evils of
sugar.
And I really believe I'm right now,
I have a lot of data and science behind
me,
but I,
you know,
I have all kinds of ideas about why
sugar is bad and fat and protein is good
for you because you know,
I've lived in and I've done it and I'm
sure you have your own point of view.
I had a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
today and it was damn good and it was
damn good and you didn't hurt anybody,
including you probably didn't hurt
yourself.
So sometimes cause you're not a
fundamentalist cause every now and then.
Thank you.
Some milk.
Ooh,
it was good.
But the other glass of milk I hope has
raw milk.
Raw cause you're going to want,
but I love raw milk.
Raw milk is the shit.
I get the rock coat milk from Erewhon
and coat deep.
You know you can get to hold it.
Hold on your horses and I think it's
about $35.
I've never bought it.
But you can get camel milk.
Whoa.
Oh yeah.
What?
Talk about the Middle East.
The Bedouin famed for their sexual
prowess lived on camel milk.
Do you mean milk like as in titty milk
or sucking cocks?
No,
no,
no.
I'm talking about,
God dammit.
No,
I meet titty milk.
Almond Milk Crates,
wink.
Wait,
go man.
I'm not talking about Dick Milk.
I'm talking about,
I'm not talking about guy cream.
You fuck.
I'm talking about fucking camel milk
from their utters in a Australia day
hunt camels and the,
they have no,
like Australia is kind of a crazy place
and Australia,
New Zealand are very similar in that
they don't really have any natural
predators because they were,
they were separated from the rest of the
planet when that whole Pangea thing
happened.
So all they have is like they have
crocodiles,
but crocodiles are,
for the most part,
they only get things that are really
stupid.
They get things that are,
that are forced to go through rivers.
That's what they get.
They get things through to close to the
water.
Guys are fishing in waist deep water,
but they have so many animals that
crocodiles are just not going to get
like Kangaroos.
They're not going to kill all the
Kangaroos.
It's just not going to happen.
So they have to bring in people to kill
camels.
That's crazy.
They have to bring in people to kill a
lot of on camels are indigenous to
Australia or where they brought their,
they were brought there.
Here's what's crazy man.
All the animals were brought there.
They tried to turn Australia and New
Zealand into some incredible hunting
destination for old school.
He rich dudes and like the 18 hundreds
really?
Yeah.
They totally violated the all the laws
of ecosystem.
No,
that,
yeah,
because they brought these animals over
and they didn't bring over companion
predators.
So you have wild stags where they've
never had any Predator Chai.
They're roaming through the woods and
you know how to take care of them.
They fly overhead with helicopters and
gun them down and let them rot.
Really?
Yeah.
They have to control the population.
They literally sometimes are forced with
some of these animals to gun them down
and just leave them there.
It's delicious meat.
They don't have a problem with me.
They have a surplus of me.
You know?
Most of the venison that we get is from
New Zealand.
When you get elk,
it's from New Zealand and they brag
about it.
And New Zealand elk filet.
Yes.
Yeah.
Colorado's right there.
Like how was it?
What the fuck is going on over there?
I tell you what's going on over there.
No mountain lions.
No bears,
no wolves,
no coyotes.
And know people,
put a couple of families,
wolves out there.
It was,
it just kill the shit out of everything.
I leave till the shit out of everything.
It's like,
Hey,
let's have some fun today.
There was an interesting story that I
posted,
um,
a couple of days ago that I read on one
of the,
um,
I think,
uh,
one of them outdoorsy type websites,
but it was about a guy talked about how
his dog got killed by wolves and that he
wasn't mad at the walls.
He found his dog's head.
He couldn't find the dog and she was
like 18 years old German shepherd.
And he went walking,
trying to find her and then found her
head and it was like,
oh my God,
who did that?
Why would anybody do that?
He thought it was a person,
like some crazy serial killer.
And then he realizes he got further on a
lot of evidence of a wolf attack.
If you've ever seen,
you know what a wolf does?
We came pawn,
I'm a wolf calf that had been killed,
not a wolf cafe,
a moose calf,
others that had been killed by wolves
in,
um,
in Canada when I was there about a year
and a half ago.
It was actually two years ago now.
Um,
and it was really weird because I didn't
expect to see all the hair and I was
like,
Oh yeah,
of course they'd have to like get rid of
the hair.
Yeah.
Well they say spit it up and they chew
it up.
But it was,
I always just thought like when you
would find a carcass,
then it'd be just like torn apart.
It's not just torn apart like Harry's
everywhere.
Yeah.
It's like all over [inaudible] balm.
Did you see,
I have that picture up there.
See if you could find the moose calf
killed by a,
I've seen that.
Have you seen that in living in the
wild?
What?
Did you see?
A hair everywhere?
Um,
I can't remember.
I saw,
I saw it was something in Topanga
Canyon.
Actually we are coyote gets a hold of a
um,
a rabbit and there was right in Topanga,
there was a deer that had been killed by
a mountain lion.
Whoa.
Bones.
And look at that.
Look at all that hair.
It's like a,
like a blanket of hair.
That's crazy.
Like hey in the bottom of a farmer or a
barn or something.
But look,
they had chewed all the meat off the
face.
Everything.
Hazing.
It's from a night.
It's from 96 weeks ago.
Wow.
Look at that fucking picture.
That,
it's crazy.
We found that because of crows
crows were,
yeah,
we were walking down this road and these
crows started circling overhead and my
friend Mike Hawk Ridge,
he's like,
let's go see what they're squawking
about.
So you don't want to walk with your dog
on trails then in Wolf territory?
Well you know what man?
Wolves for the most part we'll avoid
people.
A dog usually means just people.
But if the dog gets crazy and goes
chasing after him gets away,
they'll take that thing out.
And even if they're not even trying to
eat it,
they might take it out.
Cause it's a competing Predator,
right?
Like I'm,
I'm reading this Dan Flores book,
um,
called the coyote America and it's all
about,
I found out about them from Rinella,
his podcast.
He was Vanillas,
I'm a natural history professor,
I think.
You think he's a,
he's,
he's a,
either a wildlife historian,
one of those.
But his whole deal is,
I'm studying the history of an animal in
a certain part of the world is coyote
book is fucking fast.
And why,
what,
what does he talk about?
First of all,
they're all the same thing.
Coyotes or wolves.
Yeah,
they're all wolves.
So like when people would talk to them
about these coy wolves,
those coy wolves would probably like a
red wolf or an eastern wolf.
Fuck the coyote and that thing.
Fuck the coyote.
Wow.
And they're all like,
like 20%.
Yeah.
There's like 10% wove and 20% well
there,
there's not like a 50 50 thing going on.
There's like all these crazy inner
breeds.
And the bottom line is they're all the
same animal.
All wolves is Haman.
Not only that,
all canines emanated in North America.
How about this?
All horses evolved in North America,
including the same from the US.
They came from the Asian steppes.
I thought so too.
They all have,
they all made it over there millions of
years ago from America.
Here's the really fucked up thing.
They don't know why they went extinct in
America.
Horse has started in America when
extinct in America thrived in other
parts of the world and were reintroduced
to America.
That's so weird.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
And I showed the video of me being
surrounded by coyotes.
No,
I'll start it yet.
Um,
can you sound Jamie and I'll play it and
let me,
let me try to find it.
Yeah.
But the,
the point being is that there's this
really nutty history that I had no idea
about.
All of these animals,
jackals in Africa emanated from North
America,
started out as canines here.
Those fucking things spread everywhere.
I've Seen Fox,
uh,
and,
and uh,
here in California when I was hiking and
I've seen Bobcat,
I've seen Fox in Colorado,
but I've seen bobcats out here.
But here's the deal.
The,
the really crazy thing about coyotes
versus a,
any of these other animals,
because the fact that gray wolves were
like their competitors,
they're the bigger dog.
They used to kill them.
They developed all these different
methods of staying alive.
And one of them is when they scream out,
you know that that's a role call.
That's what they're doing.
They're really roll call.
Yeah.
Because some shit's gone down.
Maybe they've killed something.
We want to make sure everybody's around.
And when someone's missing,
when someone doesn't respond,
it goes missing.
The female produces more pups in her
litter significantly.
Yeah.
There's some sort of a biological effect
when one goes missing and she can go
from four if it's a healthy population
to like 16.
So here's,
here's what,
how they,
one of the ways that they know that this
is a fact that these wolves are capable
of doing this is that when they
introduced wolves to yellowstone,
wolves hadn't been in yellowstone since
they eradicated them.
Right?
So these people came across North
America,
killed all these wolves.
And the way they would do it is through
using their system of uh,
communicating and using their,
um,
the fact that they're there,
these tight knit groups and these packs
and their families and they stick
together.
So they would kill one wolf rub.
It's sent all over a carcass,
inject the carcass of a horse who would
shoot a horse and Jack the horse would
strychnine so that way they're killing
two birds with one stone right there.
We're getting rid of the wild horses,
which had become a real problem.
And they are still a problem today.
Like wild horses.
They kill wild horses in America all the
time.
Yeah,
I didn't know that either,
dude.
It's nuts.
And the fact that there's thousands,
tens of thousands of wild horses in
North America right now to the point
where they're the thousands,
tens of wild horses in America.
There are people that are advocating for
the hunting season of wild horses.
I'm real.
Yeah,
that's a lot of meat.
It's a lot of meat.
It's like an elk.
Yeah.
It's funny because if you'd shot,
that'd be a great deal of protest
properly.
Cause we know horses,
we ride them.
It's like dogs man.
Yeah.
But these animals all started here.
It's really bizarre.
That is so strange there.
This he gets into on Renell's podcast,
the mass extinctions that occurred
somewhere in the range
of the last ice age and maybe some time
even before that,
some of them and how,
how little they know about what killed
mall cat.
And there's all this speculation.
Is that the eye,
there's speculation that when the
buffalo,
you know started to go extinct,
they had already started.
Well apparently the native Americans
that were on horseback and we're riding
and with followed the buffalo were
killing.
They weren't like that sustainable with
their practices.
Yes.
Well this was when they started hunting
with rifles on horseback was rifles.
So this is all Dan Flores.
This is he,
he advocates the,
the possibility,
not advocates but he brings up the
possibility that they could have
possibly extra painted those animals
from there.
Their areas just based on rifles and
horsebox without the market meat farm.
So they're marketing beings,
market hunting.
When when they started market hunting
that's when everything went fucked up.
Cause they would kill apparently
thousands and thousands of buffaloes and
just cut the tongue's out.
Really?
Yup.
Why?
Cause the tongues were worth money.
People like to eat buffalo tongues.
It's like a delicate one.
I will not eat brain or tongue.
I can't find my coyote.
Steph.
I'm sorry.
That's all right.
Let's put it down.
I can't find,
I,
I can't eat tongue or brain.
I'm down for either.
It doesn't,
I like things really.
Tom.
Oregon's.
I don't need Oregon's either.
I'm not into kidney.
You ate liver.
I,
I'll eat liver.
But even liver I eat because you know
I'm there and I'm not sure what men,
yeah,
let's eat liver.
But overall,
fuck off.
Fuck off with your organs.
I'll eat heart heart's not bad.
That road deer I killed in London,
in England and I would shoot and things
in London.
It was ridiculous.
But he's got,
my friend has so much property,
has to kill 21 dear.
He has to kill 21 deer on his property
every year.
Wow.
That's how rich he is.
Yeah.
And uh,
so she ate it.
Yeah,
we ate it.
And it was the crunchiest and it made me
sick and the warden said,
hey,
that's a road dear.
You got to hang that for three weeks.
Could you just skin it,
cut it up and eat it with a good glass
of wine?
I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
no,
not with that kind of mean.
What's wrong with the meat?
It's,
and I'm not exaggerating,
it's crunchy.
Like,
like,
like um,
like the way you would if you just cut
it up and put it in a plant and fried it
with butter.
It crunches almost like a carrot.
How about that?
Yeah.
That's how hard the meat is.
Why?
Huh?
That's why he got to hang it for three
weeks and let it break down.
You cannot eat that deer meat like that.
It's a Roe.
Deer heard that before.
Well I,
I would imagine deliver that tastes like
that word crunches.
And the same thing with this,
and I'm talking about the muscle meat.
The Muslim,
we both got sick.
I was,
I wasn't right for three days.
Really.
My buddy wasn't ready for a week and the
game warden was like,
you got to hang that.
That's a road dear.
You got to hang that.
Somebody I'm sure knows about this,
but Zana practice hanging meat is oh
three waiting for things to rot minimum
of three weeks.
I know a lot of guys who do that in
their frigerator they do their own
version of a dry age age.
Yeah.
You're putting it on like a flat tray
with like a Napkin underneath it.
Fucking delicious.
By the way.
Fucking Galicia.
It's so weird.
When you go to the butcher,
if you ever go to whole foods and you
pass by the butcher,
you can look in that window into that
dry aging room and just look at rock.
Like my kids were like,
what the fuck is that?
I'm like,
that is um,
that's rot.
It's on the,
on the outside of the meat.
They're going to cut that away and yeah,
that's what it looks like.
Cheese cheese is just full of mold and
cheese is full of mold,
but it does.
We don't identify with cheese,
no cheese,
just some foreign substance.
When you look at that steak,
like you understand that that's supposed
to be red,
like meet amazing as it's a bizarre
practice.
Five day dry look at it,
starting to shrivel up.
God,
it's weird.
Right down.
Break it then fuck it is weird.
Right?
It's weird that people figured that out.
Yeah,
I didn't know that about roe deer.
So they must be like super muscular or
something.
There's not a lot of meat and they're
small and they're heart.
It's not,
you shouldn't and you're not,
you don't feel very good.
It's like the size of a fucking,
you know,
like a midsize dog.
Shit,
I'm going to lose like a collie and plus
they're not really hot.
It's,
I didn't know what was really going on.
It was nibbling away and it wasn't,
you know,
I was like,
aw man.
I had this,
I had this $15,000 a German,
a sniper rifle.
It's called a Blouser,
I think.
Blouser Lahser and uh,
and I had a,
and he had,
I was d I shot at standing up,
I had a stand.
You saw the video and you know,
listen,
it wasn't very far away.
If dude,
there's a video apparently this thing of
roe deer and it goes back to the same
thing we were talking about with um,
Australia not having any natural
predators.
These roe deer,
they bring in snipers to take them out
in England.
High speed video footage where they blow
their heads off their brother heads off
with plastic bullets.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
The plastic,
yeah,
these plastic bullets.
Yeah,
because I saw that guess plastic bullets
just don't make it through there and hit
anything else.
Like once they hit that,
it probably just explodes.
Yeah.
But the heads explode.
I mean,
have you seen it?
I'd like to see like a child's toy.
You know those child's toys that you
squeeze and the eyes poked out of the
head like that.
I was like,
well yeah,
that's what's sick is that I've not only
seen it many times,
I've thought about it,
you know,
as recently as a week ago,
you have to think about it.
It's just like a crazy thing that here's
this deer moving around and then here's
its head exploded and anything would
happen to the human being does and they
have to do it or those things will
overpopulate.
So it's like either that or do you,
I'm sure you've seen that video because
it was
really interesting video,
how wolves change rivers.
It was about the yellowstone wolves
being reintroduced into yellowstone and
how they've changed the course of the
rivers because they've killed deer,
which allowed these plants to grow that
didn't grow before and change the course
of the re.
Yeah,
really interesting stuff.
Really interesting stuff about the
reintroduction of wolves.
But it's essentially what biologists
were trying to do by reintroducing
wolves was introduced,
uh,
a natural ecosystem because this is how
it's supposed to be.
There's not supposed to be like the
hunters got upset because all of a
sudden these,
uh,
elk herds are devastated and there's
like 50% of them.
But in many ways it's kind of like a
selfish feeling because although I side
with them and I understand what they're
saying,
I don't want to wolves to be a problem
with people,
but they are,
they're a part of that whole thing.
They were there when the elk were there.
There's never elk without the wolf.
And when there are elk without the wolf,
you get what you got to New Zealand,
yet people flying overhead with
helicopters,
gutting them down and sletten the meats.
No top Predator.
Right.
And it's,
it also feels fucked up.
Like if you,
if you were over in New Zealand,
we're going hunting and as we're going
up the hill,
man,
what a beautiful countryside and let all
of these animals,
and then we hear a helicopter fly
overhead and one one ridge over there
just gone and down stacks.
And we go over the top of the hill.
And this is like what we're,
you know,
we romanticize his trip.
We're going to go there.
We're going to live off the land,
right?
We're going to take a stag.
You.
Thank you stag for giving me your life.
Your,
your flesh will feed my meanwhile,
there's a fucking helicopter just
indiscriminately gunning him down
because there's too many of them.
Shit in the grass.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
And they just let them run up there,
man.
And it's a Chi being there with my knife
taken off a bunch of steak and that's
what we'd be doing.
We'd camp right,
but we'd be bummed out and we wouldn't,
I wouldn't shoot an animal.
I'd be like,
well,
I can't eat.
There's no way I could justify shooting
an animal.
There's no way this is,
there's meet here.
It's just killed.
We're done.
Right?
So we're just going to chalk this off to
an experience.
That's it.
Just be a bit,
we talk about on stage,
oh,
here's the deer's head.
Exploded.
Cute.
That's very cute.
When it might been a fall.
Is it a button by going?
Good Lord has got a good shot.
He shot.
That's what the plastic bullet.
Yeah.
Apparently they use plastic bullets
because they're doing them in urban
environments because they're using rf
suppressors,
plastic bullets.
And Bob Lang take it out.
Yeah.
There's a place in Pennsylvania where
they allow deer hunting all throughout
the year because there's so many fucking
deer and people set up.
Tree stands in their backyards and the
higher hunters or or like advertise for
punters to come and shoot their deer.
My mother in Connecticut,
we had,
she would plant flowers and she was
obsessed with our flowers and the deer
would come in and eat them and my mother
in very soon walked into my room and
said,
listen to me,
I'm going to buy a crossbow and you're
into this shooting stuff.
I want you to kill the deer.
And I said,
okay,
uh,
it's very illegal though.
And she says,
I know so you're going to have to be
very careful.
I said,
I know,
but I think it's super early like we can
get in big trouble.
She said,
that's not the point.
I want you to kill the deer that are
eating my flowers.
I said,
you do it.
I didn't because I talked her out of it.
I was like,
listen,
you got to put a fence over your fucking
flowers because I think we could get
fine like $100,000 or something crazy
for your flowers and that's probably not
worth it.
Yeah,
you can go to jail.
But I know a lady,
I wasn't,
I didn't know how to use a crossbow.
I just,
I didn't know.
I was like,
it'd be cool.
But that's the beautiful thing about
crossbows.
You don't have to do the learning curve
super short.
Just as long as you're resting it on
something,
you don't punch the trigger.
This is all you have to learn how to do
it across what?
Ready,
Eh,
don't jerk it.
Don't jerk it.
Cause there's an instinct to juggle.
Just go like that's his goal.
Glitter it out.
Three quarters of the witch schoolies
gently Vega all on the trigger sooner.
Just moves.
Chigger doesn't even know what's going
on the trip.
You just,
just,
just push,
push,
read.
The real reason I didn't do it,
I remember is a not because I didn't
think I could do it.
It was more because I figured if I shot
the deer with a crossbow or a bow and
Arrow,
it would run and I'd have to track it
and it would run into somebody else's
yard.
And then they'd find a deer that had a
bow and Arrow and then they'd come and
find,
they trace it back.
I heard a story about a rich lady in
Malibu.
They may have done the exact same thing,
trimming letter actually shot a fucking
deer in her backyard with a crossbow.
Really?
Because it was eating her flowers may or
may not have.
Yeah.
It's May or may not have.
It's one of those weird stories you're
hearing from other moms and you know,
people talk to them.
You know what Mary did?
Oh,
she got a chronicle meet.
You know,
I wouldn't do that if I could get away
with it.
It's good meat seat.
It,
it's,
it's a good move.
It's,
you know,
it goes to that age old problem that a
lot of us have with the idea of death.
I don't want anybody to kill me and eat
me,
you know?
So why,
why do I want to kill that animal and
eat that animal?
And we have this very strange
relationship with these animals now,
sort of.
We've like,
we've contracted all of our food
collection off to other people.
Yeah.
And that's something that just didn't
exist for most of human history.
So over the last x amount of years,
we've contracted all of our food
acquisition.
I love the fact that I could just get
this plastic thing of water and I know
it's legit crocodiles.
I to hear this,
listen,
Hey,
that little snap,
that means nobody poisoned it.
It's fresh.
Yeah,
it's sealed fresh from the factory.
And I can have a nice glass of water.
I don't have to go to a river.
I didn't have to pump.
I don't have to have a,
well,
it's,
it's way better this way.
But the problem is by us not being in
nature at all by not interacting with
animals at all.
We've allowed these monsters to develop
these slaughterhouses.
He's houses of horror.
He's a factory farm mechanisms like
we've really fucked up.
We've gotten so big,
or the cities that don't make food,
need so much food on a daily basis,
that we've completely removed ourselves
from the process of,
of growing things of,
uh,
of we've like,
it's one of the most important things
about being a person as eating healthy
food.
Yeah.
It's one of the most important things.
If you don't have healthy food,
you're not going to be healthy.
It's really that simple,
right?
Like if you eat fucking just peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches like I did
today,
if you have that all day,
every day for the rest of your life,
you're gonna have a shitty short fucking
life.
You're not going to make it.
There's not enough nutrients in that,
but we don't,
we don't think about it,
man.
We're so busy with stocks and with
marriage and with fucking,
I want to get,
where are we going to thinking about,
um,
making an addition on the house.
No,
we're going to get that man cave
anytime.
It's easy though.
We've got,
we have figured out a way to get a lot
of protein in people's bodies had cheap
for cheap and he used to be that meet
with something that countries I remember
and a lot of countries that I lived in,
uh,
we were like,
for example,
you would eat and meet twice a year,
the bedouin,
you know,
who are very healthy people.
They lived on dates and bread and,
and go a camel milk and stuff.
But they,
the traditional indigenous people of
Saudi Arabia,
for example,
they would eat meat twice,
three,
four times a year,
meet with a real delicacy.
It was very expensive.
You'd,
you'd have a goat.
But it was,
it was not easy to come by.
There was very little water and stuff
like that.
So in a way we have,
we've given ourselves a food problem,
you know,
it's just the pendulum has,
we have people at eat obviously too
much.
And then you have lobbying efforts to
get as much corn syrup and things like
that into people's bodies.
And you know,
it's,
it's an interesting thing.
I think you're right though.
We've gotten away from a lot of the
stuff that just is easy to do to make
yourself healthy.
Like sleep and water.
That's a big part.
Those are giant.
The sleep of water,
a giant.
I just think we're,
so,
I think we're way too removed from what
I think is an essential aspect of life.
The process of food acquisition,
I think it makes people really confused.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I could look at it as an enthusiast and
I can look at it as someone who enjoys
being outside.
I enjoy,
I enjoy the woods,
I enjoy fishing and all that stuff.
I enjoy catching something in the water
and then cooking it and eating it.
I enjoy this so much.
You don't have to show his money in the
food business and then it good and bad.
I mean,
you know,
I don't want to make the food companies
have to be,
but I was going to say is,
but I don't want to do it every day and
I don't want it to be the only way I can
survive because it's too hard to do
anything else.
So we figured out a way to make it
really easy to get food.
The hardest part of life now becomes the
easiest part of life.
Well,
I mean,
when they talk about why did philosophy,
why were the Greeks,
you know,
able to sit around and think,
so you had plato and socrates and
Aristotle.
Well,
you know,
William McNeil I think wrote this book
about the fact that,
you know,
the Greeks had access to timber,
olive oil and wine,
and they were to export those things and
exchange them for goods that they
needed.
So it meant that they didn't have to
live a subsistence lifestyle.
They also lived in a temperate climate,
so they didn't have to spend so much
time getting ready for the winter flip.
Also,
super busy.
But fuck,
they were doing a lot of butt fucking as
well before there were,
there were any probably diseases,
but they didn't have any diseases back
then.
Now.
Yeah,
right.
Just died by plagues,
but entire civilizations.
But you know the,
in a way,
when you're able to get your food
quickly like that water,
it leaves time for other things like God
casting.
Oh yeah.
No,
it's,
look,
it's an awesome thing.
I'm not saying it's a bad thing.
I think it would be real nice if we
could all in some way reconnect the,
it'll give us a little bit more
perspective on things because the w the
world that we have right now is the best
world that's ever lived for sure that
ever lived,
that ever existed.
I mean,
this,
this civilization that we're existing in
right now,
no question.
Best ever.
There's no question.
It's just so much easier to be informed.
So much easier to improve yourself.
So much easier to get feedback.
So much easier to communicate with
people,
get to know things and there's trust.
There's trust in institutions.
I've,
at least in this country that,
you know,
when you just said I,
this is freshwater from a factory,
you know,
you don't know what went into it,
but you trust that when you drink that
water,
it's from whole foods.
You're not going to die of.
Yeah.
Nobody poisoned that water.
Nobody took shortcuts.
There's not feces in that water.
A lot of countries you couldn't say that
because you don't know who's taking,
who's running control and who's got the
government,
their pocket.
But we're really lucky in this country
that we have institutions we can trust
like a police force.
We can trust overall.
I know there's certain crops,
the FBI,
there are uh,
the courts.
There is objective law.
Those things are fucking,
we're so lucky that we all have things
like due process and representative
government.
I don't have to worry about a police
force knocking on my door.
Sometimes you do.
I guess if you've been up to stuff,
but I don't have to worry about it.
Somebody who has more power than me
buying a government official who can
then knock on my door and put me in jail
on trumped up charges.
Are there examples of that?
Maybe,
but for the most part other than a
country where that's not the case.
Thank God.
I don't know why I just took this one.
A Fox News rent.
You should get that Gig,
bro.
That's right.
That's going to get you the Fox News
Gig.
I can't,
well,
Fox News,
if they could just take Donald Trump to
task a little more polite.
How about you right next to Alex Jones
and you'd be like the voice of reason,
you know,
like they have a hannity and colmes it
callen and Jones.
Oh,
well listen,
I,
I just read your boy Michael Schirmer's
book skeptic,
which I really liked.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
And Michael Shermer is created at,
taken on the conspiracy theorists.
Well,
you know,
he's great at being reasonable about
things like he was,
uh,
he broke down the whole fire walking
thing and he explained how he did it and
he was explaining in a scientific way
that's about conductivity.
It's like there's a reason why we don't
cook on the coals themselves because
they're not very good conductors of
heat.
It's why heat up metal and the metal
grate that goes over your grill.
You Cook on that.
Yeah.
You don't want to walk on that.
He's like,
when you walk on those coals,
it's like it takes a while for you as
long as you move quickly.
Yep.
You don't spend too much time with one
spot,
you're going to get all right.
He's like heels.
He gave us an actual scientific
breakdown.
He goes,
after about 10 to 15 feet,
it kind of gets crazy.
Yeah.
Cause then it's just too much time of
you touching the coals,
but he's like eight to 10 feet.
You're okay.
Him and Sam Harris,
who?
My favorite guests on your pocket.
They're both great.
They're both fascinating in their own
right.
They're both,
uh,
you know,
guys that we really,
really need where there's,
there's a lot of nutty shit out there.
Like they came on or he came on rather
Michael Shermer.
One of the things that he wanted to talk
about with this increased presence of
people that honestly believe that there
is some sort of a conspiracy,
that the earth is flat and that can't
even get,
I can't,
I don't have the energy.
I do.
Ah,
I have the attorney just to,
would you look at it and quick bursts
like the same thing.
I have the energy to hold my breath.
That's my same energy for flat earth.
Hold my breath and I'll watch like a few
minutes of a youtube video that I go,
yeah,
I have to shut it off like you're going,
you're saying a bunch of shit that
doesn't make any sense.
Why does water spin to his fee attached
with spending goal?
If we really worse round water would
spill over the side.
Fuck,
listen,
you're not a fucking,
you know,
you're not a physicist,
going up on our Youtube Channel,
oh,
it drives me to hates coming.
I've met more people mad at me and I
retweeted one the other day.
I put up a real tweet from a real person
that believes the earth is flat.
She shot me.
He was saying it was a sell out.
I know where your checks being cashed,
bro.
How come I hashtag flat earth like
Hashtag flat earth is a real thing.
14 listen.
Schermer sets on a great schirmer said,
you know when you have people reaching
the same conclusion from independent
lines of inquiry,
you got so many different independent
lines of inquiry.
People are doing their own research and
they all converge on one conclusion.
If you are then coming in to say,
well this is my idea.
If you're a conspiracy theorist said,
well yes,
but there's all this unexplained
phenomenon,
that's fine.
But you know when I asked for it
evidence,
you know what I always get when I say
why did it happen?
And they go,
it's been covered up dude.
People are being killed with now is a
bunch of Liars and 1100 scientists lied
about the earth moon landing.
I mean,
come on,
sorry,
a Christmas letter obviously.
Who's signing your checks now?
They spelled q three from an island.
I think they do that in England too.
Maybe flatter doesn't need a washed up
failure anyway,
Hashtag flat Earth Ah man.
But here's the thing,
there's video taken from the space
station of the earth being round and
have them circling the earth.
There's time lapse video.
You could see time lapse video of the
Sun rising and falling,
like you could see it.
I'm not even talking about this.
I know,
but I mean,
what do they think that is?
That's all fake,
right?
Then all those people are liars.
One has ever gone up.
Their satellites aren't real.
Did you know that's another one they do?
No.
Yeah.
They think that satellites are actually
low flying planes.
I find they're probably just at the end
of the day,
they need to belong to a group and they
want to be exclusive.
It's a little bit like,
it's a little bit like the modern art.
When Ann Rand I ran was walking through
the museum of modern art and they were,
a bunch of people were kind of clustered
around that broom that had been stuffed
into a pail and everybody was like,
that's not interesting.
And uh,
it was really expensive.
Then they went in and there was just a
three light bulbs that had been strung
together,
hanging and,
and when,
when,
wait a minute,
I know what the fuck is going on here.
These people are all trying to belong to
an exclusive group and they're not
really even looking at this art.
They just want to be,
you know,
part of the cool kids that get it.
You don't get it cause you're not
sophisticated.
But I,
I get that they don't play chess and
they don't collect wine.
So this is their shot.
This is their shit.
It's a community.
You have to go to Lacma.
Uh Huh.
Oh sure.
How to La,
what is it?
La County Museum of art.
What does that a white tapestry.
You mean?
He just took a light tapestry and framed
it,
but it's,
it's the,
it's the texture of the wine.
It's eggshell white.
They had a plexiglass box.
Of course they did.
It was a,
is there like an amber colored?
It was a small box.
It was about maybe two feet high,
maybe three or four feet wide.
And it was,
it was a roped off with wire.
You couldn't get close to the touch it
because it was art.
Well this I,
I spoke to this amazing artists who owns
the comedy cellar in New York City.
She owns the building and the comedies
[inaudible] and her name is a Alva and
she has her,
have you ever been to the comedy store
in New York?
Sure.
So I'm sorry.
The comedy cellar she had,
if you look on the wall,
there are all these amazing awe,
awe.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's,
people were sitting on it though,
so they had a rope it off.
Genius.
You can't sit on art.
It'd be good to sit on amazing in a
really uncomfortable way.
It's an amazing piece.
That's amazing.
Incredible.
In your home front swap the Bel Air
Home,
I'm just thinking creates amber.
You could maybe put it like right at the
front door.
Like they walk in your house,
they're like,
look at what you're into.
I mean you're in for a crazy night.
Likud friends while box.
You were an artist back in the seventies
days and you do portraits are really
cool.
Like figures that you could identify
with like this.
Grow out with an amazing woman.
She's an amazing painter.
I mean like you,
well you go,
you want to buy that stuff.
She said there was no way back in the
day that she could even,
like,
people wouldn't even really teach you
how to draw human famous.
It was too literal.
Too literal.
You,
you weren't getting into a school,
you were getting into Cooper Union or
anything because you were just too
literal.
You were not part of this ICT guys.
That is the abstract movement and that's
how human beings are.
Did you,
when you see like a Jackson pollock,
did you ever,
you ever go,
wow,
that would be cool to have or do you go,
what
in the fuck?
I don't know enough about art,
which I with point of view,
but he was,
he was,
he was a groundbreaker I guess in some
ways in that he said he was doing
something,
get the fuck out of here.
Yeah.
He was a groundbreaker in splashing
paint like a little kid would do well,
but then he did,
he was doing something,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't want,
man.
All you have to do is like get in with
the right group.
You know,
you do acid and below woody allen,
you smoke cigarettes.
He yell at your secretary,
I paint would go,
he's brilliant.
He's brilliant.
He's amazing.
The guy's just standing over at this
point and you know,
hey man,
if you're one of those guys out there
that you like,
fuck you Joe Rogan.
I'm a big Jackson pollock fan.
You don't know shit about art obviously.
No,
no.
He had something else about art.
But the difference between how I see
things and how other people see things,
I'm sure he had did something else.
He was doing something actually much
more deliberate than that.
So you ready for my Jackson pollock,
a education here?
I believe Jackson pollock was painting
fractals.
I think that there was a,
there were so,
so a fractal would be,
if you look at the coastline of a,
of a country,
and then you look at the micro,
um,
what is it,
the micro sort of,
uh,
lines in that particular,
it,
they mimic the larger picture,
the larger coastline.
That would be a fractal,
I believe.
And Jackson pollock was different
because not only it was the first guy to
start doing that,
but he was deliberately creating what
other painters were not able to do,
which was fractals,
please.
Uh,
please somebody tell me that I'm right
about that personal reflections on
Jackson pollock.
So is that the case,
Jamie?
Is that what they're showing color
Palette painted nightdress fractals.
Huh?
I had to be,
well,
what fractals,
the best way to describe fractals is
it's a geometric pattern that as you get
closer to it,
you see the,
like if you look at it from a distance,
you see a very particular shape.
Like the Mandelbrot set is a perfect
example of,
of a,
an amazing fractal.
And it was one of the ones that the,
the really nutty people used as proof
that crop circles were from extra
terrestrials because mathematicians had
only figured out the Mandelbrot set.
I just,
I want to say less than a year before
this crop circle appeared with a perfect
mandelbrot set in some wheat field and
the idea of this pull up a Mandelbrot
set.
So you could see this actually an
animated version of the Mandelbrot set,
which is really the best way to look at
it because as it goes closer you can see
that it's the same thing on the outside
in a smaller scale.
And then it go you a closer than that
and it's the same thing you saw on the
outside but in a much smaller scale and
then it goes on and on.
That's apparently what what pollock was
able to do that other painters have not
been able to do.
So there was something,
here's the animation of the Mandelbrot
set,
so it's just crazy looking weird thing
that as you get closer to it and it
expands,
you start,
it starts revealing itself.
It's end.
It starts revealing how bizarre it is.
Like as you see all these little things
that stick out of these circles,
these giant circles and smaller circles
and then even smaller circles that are
attached to that giant circle and each
one of those gets infinitely smaller,
keeps repeating.
It's exactly,
and it never ends.
You keep going deep into these things
and you find another small circle and it
has smaller circles on it and you go to
Ed and the smaller circles and it just
keeps going on and on and on and on and
on.
It's fascinating.
So pull up the crop circle Mandelbrot
set and see if you could find the
history on it.
Cause I think it was like,
it was like one of those things where
they were like,
look someone who's doing these either
the hoaxer is very educated and some
sort of a mathematician and understands
the proportions in making a correct
manner or reasonably correct mandelbrot
set or daily.
I'm going with aliens,
I'm going with the audience to do more
fun.
Look at that.
Isn't that crazy though?
It's a beautiful looking little thing
someone made in the wheat field,
you know,
but the idea that it's impossible to
walk and not leave trails like oh
there's all these lines in there.
He fucks like what about those roads
like go up like it's impossible to walk,
like go to the image and make that
larger.
It's impossible to walk in there and not
be detected.
Um,
I see roads.
Do you see those fucking roads?
Yeah,
that's the problem.
These fucking people,
they never want to see everything.
I know.
They always want to like look at only
the conspiracy.
Why?
Because it's fun.
I used to be one of those people.
Yeah.
And Michael Shermer,
his book he talks about in Spanish
skeptic,
he talks about Thomas Eager,
I think mit professor who talks about
yes,
jet fuel that Burns at 2,700 degrees
and,
and steal,
you know,
it doesn't melt a,
I can't remember,
I,
Jeff Still Burns at 1200 degrees and the
steel,
the structural steel in the World Trade
Center,
that doesn't melt until it's 2,700
degrees and say,
you're right,
the jet fuel may have gotten up to 1400
degrees.
Here's the thing,
at 1200 degrees or 1400 degrees,
steel loses 50% of its integrity.
Structural steel and the steel.
And this was this guy from mit who is an
actual,
you know,
professor of engineering when it comes
to metallurgy.
You know,
and when you're at the Massachusetts
technology,
you know some shit,
you know when you're a professor.
That's why I hated that argument.
It doesn't have to just melt.
He said,
he said,
he'd say when,
when there's irregularities in that
structure over,
you know,
hundreds of feet and there are hundreds
of degrees of reg and regulators.
It will buckle.
It'll that things will buckle.
It'll break the clamps off.
And the next thing you know,
do you know what percentage,
how about this crazy thing?
This is also from Thomas Ego who is at
mit professor,
do you know what percentage of the World
Trade Center Tower,
one of them was of air?
Like what percentage was made up of the
air?
You think it was 50%.
20% meaning like if you look at the
whole structure on the outside,
how much of the inside is made of Aser?
Well,
good percentage of every building's made
of air,
right?
Cause it's like a honeycomb.
Sure.
Going on.
Yeah,
I don't,
what's a normal building?
Uh,
well,
normal buildings have a lot of concrete
and they're made it.
This is no,
this is an incredible building that was
able to,
it was basically a giant sail and it was
able to take an incredible amount of
force,
not only from planes but from wind,
like 300 mile an hour,
you know,
crazy,
crazy stuff.
And so it was an incredible feat of
engineering designed by this Japanese,
a architect and it was 110 stories high.
95% of that structure was air 95% which
is incredible.
Right.
And so when it pancake that it,
yeah,
it felt,
that's why it fell down that way.
But yeah,
for sure.
Stop making buildings that are that big.
Right.
Well,
he's settle the fuck down.
It couldn't.
It was,
yeah.
You have to make it so big.
It's big.
That's a big building.
It seems silly.
How about you make two smaller
buildings?
You fuck,
I know that,
you know,
it was a feat of Manhattan and they want
to do something awesome and revitalize
the neighborhood.
It was a revitalization project there.
The real problem with conspiracy
theories is it,
some of them are true.
That's the real problem.
When you start going over history,
you can get paralyzed by all the
possibilities because so many things
have been conspired and were pulled off
throughout history.
It's just a common thread throughout
history,
but the problem is when you're looking
at things today like towers falling and
buildings catching on fire and
collapsing and all these conspiracies
get thrown around,
you will lose a massive amount of your
life watching youtube videos and reading
websites.
No,
you ever six taking down rabbit holes
and websites,
I think dedicated to the nine 11
conspiracy.
Oh,
that's a small number,
but it's,
it's again,
it's one of those things where people
don't want to see both sides of it.
They don't want to see both sides of it.
I feel like for sure there was some
incompetency for sure.
There was some failure to understand the
threat.
Sure.
Whether that was an intelligence failure
who,
I don't know,
whatever it was,
there were some,
there was some failure.
Right,
and that allowed that whole thing to
happen.
Now,
when any fun,
when anything happens throughout
history,
there's two,
there's one,
there's two primary things that happen
when something goes down.
Number one is people capitalize on it.
If there's an enormous event,
there's something that happens,
we get attacked and you know,
they know what happens and they,
there's,
there's this,
there's this moment now in time,
right,
where they have this potential to do
things they couldn't do before because
the mood of the country has shifted.
The mood is on revenge movies on
preventative measures,
and then you can do things like go to
Iraq and invade Iraq.
That's a hundred percent fact that that
is why they did that.
They did not do that cause they thought
our rack was going to attack us.
There's no evidence whatsoever.
They didn't know the weapons of mass
destruction was all horse shit.
Right?
So the whole reason why they did is they
look okay,
we've got a tag,
but on the good side we've got a fucking
nice chance to go to Iraq here.
Now the people that are looking and
conspiracies,
they all start to add things.
So they'll start to say they engineered
those attacks so they could go to Iraq.
That's not necessarily true and way up
way unlikely.
It's also giving the government or a
group of people,
a lot of credit for organizing being
that organizations and people keeping
their mouth shut.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
that's it.
Government incompetence and random
events and momentum are probably the
reason a lot of things that things
happen.
People do have agendas.
I do think there was a group of people
that had an agenda that wanted to take
out the fourth largest army in the
world,
uh,
Iraq because Iraq was posed a threat.
But,
but,
um,
those people probably got into the
decision makers ear like George W.
Bush and not a very wise guy.
And uh,
you know,
so there,
there were people that influenced,
I think the invasion of Iraq who were
smarter than the decision makers.
Yes.
That's what I,
Bill Hicks had a great bit about the
fourth largest army in the world thing.
He's like,
yeah,
but after the first three armies,
there's a real big dropoff.
Yeah.
He goes,
yeah,
the fifth largest army is a salvation
army.
Yeah.
I think that the one of the right main
reason after nine 11 was the idea was
let's go into Iraq to show any other
country like Pakistan,
North Korea,
that if they think there's any value in
giving a weapon of mass destruction to
an enemy like Okaydo,
that it'll be the end of their country.
Here's appears proof.
You know,
there was certainly probably a little
bit of that,
but also oil money,
oil was a big factor.
The ability to sort of engineer and
control the environment of budgets.
Correct.
Engineering Control Lid was on lesson
one,
but a,
well,
no,
because other than that doesn't hold
water because the oil,
there was money in a war effort,
but oil is a commodity traded on the
open market.
So if you actually look at the way oil
is traded,
there's,
there's a a tanker with oil and it's a
war.
It's a commodity.
So it's,
it's an attack on an oil tanker can be
on its way to a country and then it's
that tanker is bought by a broker and it
has to turn course and go back to
another place.
So oil is traded on the open world
market.
There's,
there's oil that's about it.
So the idea of the United States wanted
to control the Iraqi oil is actually
bogus because we lost a shitload of
money and we don't,
we don't get that oil money.
We also produce enough of our own oil
with fracking and things to always
support it.
Yeah.
No we didn't done but let's look,
but hold on a second.
Cause look at it practically.
Does Iraq hold fucking untold billions
of gallons of oil?
Yeah.
Yes.
And isn't it a great idea to be in
control of a place that has billions of
gallons of oil?
Aren't we in control of Iraq to invade
and overthrow their government?
We did,
but we're not in control of it.
Right?
Well we're not in control,
but we essentially overthrew their
government and then gave control to
other people if we decide to take it
back.
If there was some sort of an event in
the United States decided to go in and
take it back.
There's,
it's not like they're,
they're going into North Korea.
It's not like they're going into some
established country with a powerful army
like Russia.
You know,
they're going into some thing that we
essentially broke down.
We broke down,
created a civil war between two rival
factions of Islam,
which nobody even predicted.
I had no idea you'd be new about the
area a lot more than a lot of people
that we're talking about it because you
grew up there.
I remember you talking to me about that.
I remember you explained to me at the
difference between the Shia and the
Sunni and that these people do not
fucking get along.
And this is going to,
and that it's a sodom was same guy being
a psychopath and a fucking maniac.
He is.
He was also a nonreligious person.
Yeah.
And because he was secular,
sort of bathurst is essentially
essentially mean as much as you can be
to exist in that area,
you know.
But because of that,
you know,
he kind of like controlled those people
from going after each other.
So my point being is there's a lot of
fucking money to be made in Iraq in oil
a lot.
And the idea that that wasn't some form
of motivation and how we see,
we see these conversations that people
have.
It's one of the things about these wiki
leaks,
uh,
documents that you get.
You get to see the connections at some
of these people have with arms sales and
with donations to the Clinton Foundation
and with oil and big money,
big money and so much wanting
reconstruction,
big money in weaponry,
big money in oil drilling.
There's big money in all of that stuff.
And everybody's got their hand in the
Pie.
Everybody's,
and then,
then what happens is,
you know,
you have other countries,
for example,
look at Pakistan.
Pakistan has dizzy or I love the way you
say that Pakistan has zero interest in
having a peaceful Afghanistan.
I can't even say that France falls
without making phone calls if you have
enough phones.
Uh,
so then you have other countries like
that that have less of an interest in
keeping that country stable.
So they foster conflict by supporting
criminal networks,
by supporting other vested interest in
those country,
keep those country's in turmoil.
And then you have a real problem.
And,
and the biggest issue with Eh,
you know,
if you wanted to get into a conspiracy,
my God,
this,
the Iraq invasion,
2003 was good for Iran,
made Iran a bigger player,
probably made Russia more influential
and certainly made the Shia in Iraq,
the people that finally had some power
and had control of oil over the Sunni
minority.
That is,
remember what the British,
British,
British used to always do this right?
The British would go into,
for example,
in Syria and things like that,
that the Alawites in Syria are empower.
The Alawites are a minority.
That's what Bashar Al Assad is.
And I believe the Alawites are Shia
where majority of the country is Sunni.
I believe it might be the other way
around,
but the British always would go into a
country when they would take over,
kind of colonize a country and they'd
find them minority and they would give
that minority
a lot of power.
And here was the genius of that.
They would,
they would prop them up and because now
the minority in that country had to be
loyal to the British because if they
weren't,
if they,
if they chose to now kind of side with
any kind of a revolution side with any
kind of an independence movement,
the minority also knew that once that
was over,
the majority that they had been
suppressing that they had been given
favor over would then turn on them.
So that was always a way of dividing and
conquering.
Find who the minority in the country is
and go ahead and give them power so that
they will,
they will have to be loyal to us because
they're survivable will depend on it.
Well,
there's been really bizarre moments in
history where leaders have actually
contemplated how to keep the population
under control in the event that there's
no war.
That's one of the big fears is the event
that peace breaks out.
I mean it's one of the reasons why they
constructed the,
the game of football.
They,
they made football to deal with the fact
that people weren't going to war.
And you had all these young men,
they were ready to fuck a girl to kick
some ass.
And there was no ass to keck.
You know,
they had conquered America.
They had wiped out all the native
Americans and put them into reservations
and that.
So that was a sort of unspoken war.
And then there was the wars with the
British and the wars with the Spa
Spanish and all this different shit that
went on for how many hundreds of years.
And I'll throw out the question men,
what was that?
The great article a,
I can't remember his name,
but he wrote an article goes,
I don't,
I never trust anybody.
Hasn't been punched in the face.
And he said,
civilization is an agreement among men
to behave well.
And you know,
when you got civilization it's fine.
But look at the simulated violence at
all of us have to engage in I at 49
going box,
look at the UFC.
I never miss a fight.
I,
you know,
I want to see it.
I,
there's something about that.
I think mma,
I've heard this is one of the fastest
growing sports among young men all over
the world.
Oh,
it's surprising when you see two men
should kill each other with their bare
hands.
There are triggers.
Visual triggers.
The same as like with pornography,
it's just visual triggers,
right?
You're just like,
there's that taps into my caveman there.
There's certainly some of that.
Yeah.
So we've covered a lot of ground here
and I,
I feel good about it and know that the
age of most of your father's,
and I hope you've written down
everything I fucking said.
Mm.
I'm going to be an Ottawa.
Oh by the way,
Ottawa.
What are you doing in Ottawa?
I'm doing a college there.
Uh,
September 30th and two colleges.
Do you think that I would remember cause
since we get such a wide,
you have such a fine line.
I should tell everybody where I'm going
to be.
Do I know I'm hopeless.
Just text me and I'll tweet it.
All right.
And we'll be in a,
we're sold out in San Jose.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
This September,
20 seconds and shy so she will go,
Joe Rogan is and lied to me.
I'm like,
I didn't say I was going to be there and
her job and I find it and get it in
October 13th.
Tickets available.
Bria Bria
in California this weekend.
This weekend.
Uh,
we are going this Thursday.
I'm going to be in San Jose.
What about Friday and Saturday?
I'm around.
You want to work?
Actually Friday,
Saturday I have cakes and son of a,
by no Friday I'm in Ventura.
Not Know where you are.
If I am adventure at Saturday,
I am at uh,
UC Santa Barbara doing standup to
another college.
Yeah,
he smarty pants.
Do you get out there with a book and
start reading and you don't want to be a
little edgy and I like to see how far I
can push it.
Like last time I did you see UC Santa
Barbara?
I said,
um,
maybe don't think,
I know you guys think that you're the
center of the universe.
Maybe.
Maybe put yourself last in all
categories.
Maybe you're not that important.
It might be good.
We,
it was this unempowering.
I don't like the way you think.
Well,
but,
but we live in a world where it says
self my kids,
I'm gonna fucking yell at the school.
You're not that important.
Your dreams are going to important.
Mike kids went down there to get an
education,
not to be taught by some fucking 49 year
old burn out,
but you're not in Paul.
But he looks a lot younger than 49.
He's got tight fitting skin from a
distance,
from a distance,
from a homes.
I think about getting old.
Yeah,
you should.
You're getting old.
It's why training.
That's why I do my yoga has no getting
around it buddy.
I know.
It is what it is.
Um,
I think we saw it a lot of the problems
I think,
I don't think we solve shit and I don't
think this is what I think.
I think the world's perspective is a lot
like my lego pile that I was talking
about.
Little tiny legos get put on all the
time and sometimes we have to take legos
off sometimes.
Like we've created areas of protection
where we don't really need any
protection.
The big,
big one being humor.
I can people try to dissect humor and
pretend that these are actual
statements,
like you're giving a fucking affidavit
in court or something like that.
Like people say ridiculous things.
They don't really mean.
That's why you laugh at them cause you
know they don't really mean it.
You know,
and the,
the idea that you're allowed to get
triggered by these things and you know
you're allowed to protest to get upset.
It's,
it's just a symptom of us being too
soft.
Just a symptom of life being too soft
and gentle snowflakes.
I couldn't agree more fragile
snowflakes.
I couldn't agree more so scared but get
some perspective.
Yeah,
they can't so much worse if shit went
down just like it did on nine 11 then
you get this beautiful community of
people that are happy and,
and truly thankful,
but it's almost like shit has to go down
for us to remember or you've got to do
something really hard.
I think that's one of the great things
about exercise.
Like,
sometimes I'll come out of a workout and
I fucking love everybody.
I want to hug people.
I just love endorphin trying to your
body.
Yeah,
I'm high as fuck on endorphins and on
top of the endorphin thing,
it's also like just a release of stress
and it's working out is so difficult
sometimes that when it is over,
like you have this uh,
you know,
like the struggle of a peak training
session.
Like say if you're doing rounds on the
bag right and you know you're going to
do seven rounds in the bag and you hit
that fourth round and you are fucking
exhausted.
Yes.
And you know,
you have do three more rounds and you
know,
in,
you've got to go have to go hard.
Like when it's,
it's so hard to do when you're in the
moment when your pr you're heaving and
you're looking at the clock and is still
a minute and 45 to go and you're,
and you're just breathing fire and
trying to pace yourself.
That's so much more difficult than
everything else.
Then once you get out,
everything else is like,
ah,
vince,
Vince Lombardi said fatigue makes
cowards of us all.
Yeah,
I love that.
Yeah.
I think you said of men and specific.
Hold on.
Listen,
that's back in the old days.
I'm going to be at the hook on and I
know you're going to be mad him up.
No cause I didn't want you to cause I
get made you guys make fun of me for not
being good at marketing.
Get on it.
Oh I'm going to be at the Algonquin
Commons theater and Ottawa.
Yes.
Friday,
September 30th I'll gunk when Commons
theater.
Wow.
That was so I'm not doing it cause it's
a con.
It's a theater.
What might be out of college sometimes.
Like they'll hold things like for the
whole community.
I decided have you been to Ottawa?
You had been to Ottawa.
I love Ottawa.
I love Canada.
Canada.
I'm a big fan of Toronto of sure for
sure.
I'm excited.
Algonquin common stuff.
The big fan of Vancouver,
big fan of Montreal.
I just like it up there and I like the
people better let me too.
They're nicer when shit hits the fan.
That's where I go.
Let's go out there.
We want to go hunt.
Toronto's cold as fuck cold together.
We've got to meet you.
Have you met my friend?
The Rivets?
They'll move in in Alberta.
No,
they live way the fuck up there.
They live in a log house and they shoot
bears every day.
Really?
It's just too far up there.
How about that?
The get all their meat from the woods,
man,
they're way up there.
There are two and a half hours outside
of Edmonton.
Ooh,
yeah,
maybe more.
It might be like 300 I spend a lot of
time in Edmonton.
It's a fun town too and I think there's
something about the fact that those
people have to endure on godly
temperatures.
They bond together.
It's incredible and they do a lot of
drugs,
lot of drugs,
which kind of drugs?
Cocaine and I was at,
if I was a toot head,
if I wanted a tune up,
I'd be,
oh,
I've been,
I've been offered more below in tr and
Edmonton.
God bless those people.
How do you think they get it in?
If you think about it,
right?
Canada's is way the fuck up there and
you can't even grow coke in North
America.
There's,
you know that.
No,
I think you can't be grown in the United
States Google if that's possible.
But if that's true,
I've been repeating that all my life and
I'm pretty sure I got it from an ice tea
song.
My really,
my feeling is talking about conspiracy.
I'm sure with that kind of money,
they're probably people that are border
control and stuff or getting,
it's just too easy to let it through.
I think it's from the song high rollers
and whether it be a high roller,
does cocoa beans?
Truth is cocoa beans do grow in the u s
but only in very limited areas.
Typically cocoa beans are grown in a
narrow band referred to as the coca belt
or chocolate belt.
His band exists.
It's 20 degrees of latitude.
Coca.
No,
but that's Choco.
We're talking about coco cocoa beans.
That's chocolate.
Chocolate's legal.
Know that.
Yeah.
Now we're talking about cocoa beans.
We'll actually call him about leaves.
Jamie.
It's not it's cocaine.
Coca plant.
Yeah.
Cocoa clients.
We,
so we added the OAA,
which is the chocolate stuff,
which is weird because it doesn't taste
good.
You ever have like raw cocoa?
Yes.
It's really good for you.
But it does not taste that good.
No,
it doesn't.
It's bitter.
Don't we have this some shit that we're
putting in our,
um,
butter from cocoa or something like
that?
What does it a cow.
Cow.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
But,
but Coco Coco was first processed with
milk and sugar.
That was a real kind of that,
cause we got it from South America.
Right.
And then they took it back to you,
but it didn't say illegal.
Awesome.
If you could grow it.
Yeah.
But it said it right below that or you
pull it back up,
you could see it.
People grow.
Do people grow cocaine?
Right.
Their board straight dope.
I don't know.
See if that,
but that's just a message board and I
start trying to find,
I have a question for you.
Please do.
Um,
I,
what do you think of when we do legalize
marijuana?
Right.
If it does get legalized,
it'd be a lot of,
there'd be a lot of the lobbying efforts
and stuff like that.
But why do you feel about marijuana use
and teenagers?
I don't think it's good idea,
but I would do it.
Yeah.
I was 15.
I don't think it's a good idea that for
a growing mind cause I think that we'd
contend to.
I think thc is still an mind altering
substance and just like anything else
and it has its benefits.
But I think as you're growing,
it feels like it can be for the most
part,
for a young mind,
a motivation.
Keller it could be.
I think there's a lot of factors that
could play into the big picture of who
you become.
It certainly could be one of them to
deny that it's not influential.
I think it's kind of silly.
Um,
and also to a really truly understand
the effects of it's,
uh,
the way thc if
affects the developing mind.
It's not completely understood and it's,
it's definitely under debate.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of studies that have shown
that it's actually not bad at all.
For a woman to be smoking it while her
baby's in the womb,
which is really contrary to what a lot
of people think.
Right?
But whether or not it's beneficial for a
young kid,
first of all,
it's probably,
it's,
if you think of how old you are when you
actually are an adult,
I mean we have this number,
right?
The numbers 18 right?
But your brain doesn't really fully
form,
it's not fully formed to your early
twenties right?
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a bunch of shit going on and if
you're altering
nat,
who knows what the consequences are,
you know,
like I'm find why we have laws against
drinking when you're under aged or
smoking,
not all countries seeing other
countries,
they have
less instances of alcohol abuse per
capita because it's not this forbidden
taboo thing.
I,
there's a real argument for that too,
is that kids don't like being told what
to do and when you can get away with
your friends and someone sneaks a little
fucking flask of whiskey and we all
around drinking in our
clubhouse like,
Ooh,
we're cool.
But if,
if it was legal and easy to get,
we might not be so inclined to do that.
I Dunno.
I Dunno either.
I don't know.
I know France doesn't have the same
issues,
but Russia does.
Russia being Russia and wouldn't be that
fun.
You know,
those are winters,
the winters and the fact that,
you know,
they got conquered by the Mongols for
200 fucking years also being run by it.
You also being controlled by the czar
right now and putting some,
sorry,
he's a terrifying person.
They keep fucking shooting guys that
know a lot about Russian doping for the
Olympics to keep shooting these dope and
scientists and journalists.
Yeah.
But the doping scientists,
they're dropping like flies and didn't
pay attention to that.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
There you got,
there was a conspiracy.
Oh,
that's a real one.
Yeah.
Someone's murdering those fucking
people.
They know too much and they're being
taken Russian intelligence.
Whoa.
Poisoning you with odorless,
tasteless substances that the KGB is
very good at,
or the fsm or whatever it's called now.
Uh,
and now apparently putting is revamping
the intelligence [inaudible] DOMESTICA
intelligence agency.
Putin knows that.
We know he has botox on his forehead.
I didn't know that he did.
I'm not going to admit or deny that.
As far as the way to shiny.
Yeah.
It's like an old lady at the beauty
power.
There's this journalist that wrote an
article in 2012 about him.
She's still alive but she has been
harassed.
But she basically,
you know,
talk about a gutsy woman.
Like she just basically wrote this expo
Zahn him done a lot of call him a small
mean simple minded man.
There's a lot more than that man.
What Putin is is like a throwback,
you know,
Jocko willink.
My friend is a former navy seal Jockos.
He's got a good sense of like the way he
classified,
it's like perfect goes.
He's a gangster.
Both.
Both uses of the word.
That's right.
Like the guys is running the country by
himself,
like gangster and he's also a real,
he's a real gangster.
He's one of the rare like actual
dictators where it's like,
oh you go,
he's got like a little thing in front of
him.
He's pretending that he's but the
reality,
oh,
he's the king.
He's the king of her people.
But that,
that did that since they love him.
Yeah,
he's got 80% approval rating or
something.
People love trump too.
There's something about,
first of all,
the 80% approval rating is probably a
lot like Kim Jong.
Ooh and shout a hundred percent approval
rating.
You know,
like the choices.
Well,
that Gas Kasparov,
you ever hear what he said?
Yeah.
He said that to governor pence.
Uh,
trump's running mate,
trump's running mate said,
uh,
he's a strong leader.
You can't deny it's a strong leader.
And Garry Kasparov said,
Mister [inaudible],
Mister pence,
governor pence saying a flattened me
Putin is a strong leader is like saying
arsenic is a strong drink.
Your country should be ashamed of you.
I couldn't agree more because you do
need to know the difference.
You didn't need to know that when,
when you talk about a strong leader,
a strong man in that context,
what you're really talking about is a
man who thinks he's above the
institutions of that country.
He's above the rule of law.
You are at his whim and what a strong
men do.
I'll create.
As long as you give me all your money,
I'll create security.
As long as you give me all your freedom,
I'll create security as long as you say
nothing bad about me.
What was that Dan Carlin,
my favorite quote,
they Romans created a wasteland and
called it peace.
Russia.
Russia is a one crop economy.
When's the last time you bought a
Russian?
Good.
Give me one thing.
You ever buy a restaurant up here?
Everything is from Russia.
Russian car rush,
rush,
and I'm washing machine.
Yes.
Russian.
You know nanotechnology by those big
hats.
A lot of hats with the flaps that come
down the side.
Vodka.
She isn't even that good anymore.
We make it better.
So we'd make us better.
And then you've got to dare you.
I don't even know what you're saying.
Oil.
I don't agree with any of this.
All right.
No,
you're right.
His pocket.
I think that there's also this game that
that pence guy has to play.
I mean,
he's been playing the small time
politics game now he's going global.
I mean there's this game that this guy
has to play where he has to say Nice
things about people that Donald Trump
has said nice things about,
you know,
Donald Trump has said that he's a fan of
Putin.
Yeah.
Robert Gates.
You know Robert Gates,
who was secretary of defense,
who served eight presidents over 50
years.
Okay,
Robert,
sorry.
Robert Gates,
right.
Wrote an article in the New York Times.
This is a guy who served Republican
administrations.
Look up Robert Gates for a second.
Hold on.
Look at this art.
I know,
I know it says Mike Pence as it's
inarguable that Putin is a stronger
leader than Obama.
He's in.
He's for me.
You're,
you're,
uh,
you're an ignorant miss when you say
things that are irresponsible.
Robert Gates said that Donald Trump is
not only unfit but dangerous for the
defense of this country.
He has zero idea,
the nuances that go into geopolitics,
what it takes.
He's just a,
he worked,
he operates on his gut,
his gut level,
and I think that the guy isn't even
interested in knowing what he doesn't
know.
He's telling me fried chicken with a
fork and knife.
Can't stand him.
Some collar with mom.
I don't like Hillary either.
Be honest because I'm more of a
libertarian,
but it'll taste thing.
I don't like that guy.
He's an EGOMANIAC and I think he's
dangerous.
Beyond repair,
do you think that he thought that this
was ever going to really work out this
way?
That he would actually be the Republican
nominee?
Question.
Unless he was doing it for his own
brand.
I can see him.
He's so,
everything comes back to that guy.
It's all about him,
right?
It's all about him.
And I wouldn't be surprised if,
yeah,
he said,
I'm going to run.
It's going to be good for my brand.
It's going to get make me more famous,
which is all he's ever been interested
in seams and it'll be,
it'll be good for my company and all
that.
And all of a sudden he went and hold on
man,
I'm,
I'm actually going to do this.
But I don't think he wants to work that
hard.
The presidency of the United States.
That's a hard thing to,
well,
I would assume that he has a ton of
obligations always.
Right.
And I assume all those obligations make
him a substantial amount of money.
Unlike being the president,
the president is not a substantial
amount of money in,
in well you names like after the fact
put his money and he put his company in
a trust under his kid's name and that's
not,
that's not the issue.
But I mean you really think he wants to
step away from everything and run the
country for half a million bucks a year.
I don't know.
I think that he doesn't,
I think that's a good question.
400 president has earned $400,000 annual
salary along with a $50,000 annual
expense account,
a $100,000 non taxable travel account
and the $19,000 for entertainment.
Hmm.
19,000 a year from entertainment.
Yeah.
I spend a lot more than the most recent
raisins.
Salary was approved by Congress and
President Bill Clinton in 1999 went into
effect in 2001 so Clinton was balling.
How convenient that motherfucker ball
and you wanted that 400 grand,
400 grand back then was probably a lot
of money.
I think Sam Harris Today on your
podcasts did a great job of describing
Donald Trump.
He said,
I don't know if he's ever said anything.
I've,
and I've listened to everything he said.
I mean,
I tried to listen to the speeches.
I try to listen to these interviews and
I agree with them.
I don't think that Donald Trump has ever
sent anything profound or insightful.
I've never heard him say even anything
substansive about what he would do,
about major challenges in this country
other than the fact that he would build
a wall.
Very general.
Good luck with that.
And,
and uh,
and get tough.
He get tough on law and order.
It's going to get tough luck.
Demagogues,
all demagogues in history always talked
about law and order and how we have to
get tough.
And that is another way of saying,
give me more power.
Give me more guns.
I'm going to keep things.
I'm going to enforce the law because
apparently our cities are hell holes.
But that's not true.
It's not true.
The cities have become places where a
lot of people go and they've never been
safer in the history of this country,
in New York City,
et cetera.
So,
you know,
this guy is,
he's got lots of sensationalist things
to say,
but there's very little substance long
unstylish short on substance.
But he's always been that guy.
That's his whole marketing campaign.
Well,
he's,
he was a salesman.
He sells himself.
He puts his name everywhere.
He brands things.
He's got this,
this look,
he wears nice suits.
You know,
he's got to look even with his hair.
Come on.
He knows he could cut his hair better
than that.
Yeah,
he does that shit on purpose.
He does that shit because he knows it's
like his whole thing.
His whole thing is just the whole
wackiness of it all.
Yeah.
But my issue becomes more about like
when people say he's got to be smart
because he made a lot of money.
Okay.
So we extrapolate.
We make these sort of large claims and
even I would do that.
Look,
he's an entrepreneur.
He does run a company.
He has created some value in his brand.
He did have luxury apartment.
When I think of trump,
I think of Nice hotels and nice
apartments.
I don't want to take everything away
from him.
He's had mistakes.
Entrepreneurs make mistakes.
So I don't begrudge them that.
Well,
here's the deal.
What is this becomes a problem with that
word smart.
Whether or not you just decide this
person's smart,
he's gotta be smart.
This person's smart,
she's smart,
he's smart.
And then he tried like,
Whoa,
he's got 130 Iq.
What does that mean?
You're really good at problem solving.
How good are you socially?
You know,
how good are you understanding people?
How good a conversationalist are you?
There's a lot of variables when it comes
to what is smart,
what's not smart.
Obviously that guy is fairly good at
making fuckloads of money,
right?
He's fairly good at running casinos and
hotels and restaurants is in menial
things fall apart and drop and you know
there's people lose money.
There's a lot of ups and downs when it
comes to business.
But you know,
he's flying around in jets.
He's got big houses and Shit.
I mean,
there's a lot of success there.
It's not like he lost all of his money
and he's poor.
He inherited about $200 million in,
had it whole apparatus,
including lawyers and political
connections in New York.
But he'd,
he'd,
you know,
he'd say,
well,
what I see that with a number of years,
200 millions,
but he had money before that.
You get inherited that money.
No,
before he was given like 2 million bucks
by his parents,
his alone start at first.
But this is ridiculous.
His father was a huge developer and he'd
always followed his father around.
His father was a giant developer in New
York and he inherited essentially not
only,
not only the money,
but also the political apparatus to
connections.
You know,
so much of,
of trump's,
uh,
when he bought so many of those
buildings in New York and he,
I think at the center of his empire,
15 buildings in New York City,
he bought those buildings and he got
huge tax breaks.
Again,
I don't begrudge that developers work
deals with the city and they get big tax
breaks.
But remember a lot of those deals came
from deep inside political connections
and connections to construction
companies,
many of which were owned by gangsters.
That's just the way you do business in
New York City.
Again,
I don't criticize that,
but please don't act as though you
weren't using the political system and
greasing the political palms to get and
make and hold on to your money when you
criticize other people.
But it's kind of admitting that he did
and he's saying he understands how the
system was.
Like we was talking about how we went to
Hillary Clinton's wedding relate,
like he gave her money,
he gave her money and went to her
wedding.
Yeah,
it's great lived,
which is,
by the way,
when you watch those,
those debates,
he's really entertaining.
I mean,
he is.
You can't,
you can't,
you can't begrudge people.
I don't think it's good to say that all
people that support trump are dumb or
rednecks.
I think that's prejudice and ridiculous.
There are people that are really fed up
with the way things were working.
The system democratic and Republican is
not working for them.
And there are a thousand reasons and
they're gone,
at least this guy speaking his mind and
he's just different,
you know,
I get it,
but please man,
please,
he's,
he's not the answer.
Plus,
it's kind of fun.
He's fun.
It's kind of fun when this,
this guy,
well,
the whole thing fun for us to hang out
with.
You know what I mean?
He's a guy,
you know?
Maybe if we can be assured that he
wasn't being recorded,
you could feel free.
We got a couple of pops in him.
Yes.
Yeah,
maybe.
But there's a bunch of issues with
Clinton as well,
you know,
and you look at all the stuff that's
attached to her and all the people that
think that there's something wrong with
her and what she represents and it's,
there's not one ideal choice.
And then,
okay,
Jill Stein,
who the Green Party candidate,
she just says that she thinks that 16
year old should be allowed to vote,
which is hilarious.
Yeah.
Um,
no,
they would vote for new UNICORNS and
Narnia.
The children,
they're teenagers.
Teenagers shouldn't be able to decide
their friends or future of the world.
It's crazy.
They're children.
They're living at home still like stop.
No,
no.
You don't get to decide how the world
board.
That's crazy.
That's so good.
I take about the way I thought when I
was 25 versus now.
I mean 16 I was such a monkey was a
monkey.
The idea that anybody could ask me any
questions other than wise,
my dick hard all the time.
I don't have any answers.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
My God,
I agree.
All these people that are running for
president are all silly.
They're all silly people.
You need like,
like literally would need like a Sam
Harris and then he would,
you know,
you'd need like a really smart guy who
could be pragmatic about things and then
he could appoint people who are
qualified.
I don't need to nominate Sam cause he
doesn't want to do it.
But you know what I'm saying?
Yam has his limits.
You know,
Sam,
what's interesting about Sam Harrison,
I there Sam Harris's that Sam's model
for human behavior and Sam's model for
the way things should work is that
essentially people are rational.
You know,
that,
that he'll cause his arguments for
against religion,
if you listened to some of his speeches
are listen now are this is the problem
is that,
you know,
Jonathan Heit,
who's a great thinker and they had a
debate and Jonathan Heights' set that
Sam Harris,
Sam,
you're a model for human beings.
It's a little bit outdated because
you're assuming human minds are
rational.
Uh,
human beings are intuitive.
We are emotional.
And in fact we're,
we're emotional and we will create
rationality around those impulses and
those emotions.
So even he has his limitations on how
human beings work.
And I'm sure we'd be criticizing his
point of view as well.
But I agree with it.
Stop right there because that's a giant
generalization.
Whenever someone says human beings are
this,
there's a giant percentage of us that
are totally irrational and out of her
fucking mind.
And then there's a percentage of us that
are rational and I shouldn't say us
cause I'm not necessarily sure I'm
rational.
Our personality,
we would like some parts of our,
our,
our personalities are rational parts.
I,
Hey,
you know why?
You know,
I spar in case I get in a fight.
That's how insecure I am.
Like I just want to be ready for an
imaginary scenario.
Does that make any sense?
Not really,
dude,
but when you are,
I'm losing my power.
Never had much anyway.
But do you lift weights?
Yes.
I dead lift.
I know you can't tell,
but dude,
if I'm going to show you my lower back
and my ass,
okay.
Yeah,
I worked for my court.
I'm gonna look forward to,
I believe you.
All right,
well now I feel like you're,
when we were talking about,
um,
just like someone generalizing,
people do this or people do that.
I think people are absolutely capable of
better and I think they're wiser now
than they were hundreds of years ago
when they believed unbelievably
ridiculous things.
It's not that long.
It's such a short amount of time with
how far people have come.
You know,
like we were talking about earlier when
we first brought up this Matt Leblanc,
frank putting in perspective the steps
that have been made and then the,
the progress that has been made.
It's a,
it's a strange time.
It's a strange time because on one hand
you do have these really fascinating,
really rational people that make some
great points and you go,
wow,
maybe there's hope for us.
But I think it's like when I send that
little building blocks,
he's Lego's.
You put a little tiny lego layer of
layer lego's on with each little
experience in each little of the way it
gets interpreted by people and they add
up to things.
So our version of like what reality is
now,
it keeps changing and growing and
expanding and morphing as opposed to,
you know,
a 1930s movie depiction of reality,
which is really all we have to go on.
Other than the history books.
Yes.
What do we have to do it?
We have to go on like what it looked
like to watch.
Who's afraid of Virginia Woolf like
that?
How do they talk to each other?
Who were these people like?
What is this?
How people were back then?
Because you've got the written word,
you know when you got coming closer to
the answers.
Right.
Is it,
would you say moving towards more of a
truthful model,
at least for how the world works?
I think it's so far away,
but I think it will happen quicker than
you think because I think with the
exponential expansion of technology,
it's going to accelerate all this
learning and this understanding.
It's going to,
I think one of the things that we're,
we're feeling really weird about when it
comes to the Internet,
is this a invasion effect where it's
invading our lives.
It's invading people's privacy.
It's invading your time.
People are getting addicted to checking
websites and checking their phone.
It's got this sort of invasives thing.
And when I look at that,
like the other day I was at um,
this place and all these people were on
their phone and I just stopped and I was
just looking around and all these people
are walking and talking on their phone
at holding their phone in front of them.
I'm like,
this is a takeover.
This is a takeover.
Like if that was an alien,
like it looks cute cause it's glass and
it's beautiful and it sits in your
pocket.
But if there was like an alien that came
and landed in your ear and demanded as
much time as your phone demands,
like we would think,
oh my God,
human beings,
they're minds are being taken over by
this being.
If something just climbed up on top of
your face and in and just start talking
in your ear,
hey man,
I got to my dance with me,
and they're like,
oh,
you're like sitting there like with
these aliens on your ear all day people,
people would freak out.
They're like,
oh my God,
we've got to get back to being people.
Well,
there's some weird filter between being
a person and then being a person,
communicating with people only through
technology,
only through electronics,
that you're inseparable,
inseparable from these things.
It's true.
All those things are leading us in some
sort of a weird way,
closer and closer and closer together to
a neural net.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
it's going to take place.
It's just a matter of when.
It's not a lot of,
well,
someday maybe no,
it's going to take place.
Whether or not we all choose to
voluntarily join in,
I don't know,
but it's,
I think it's going to be just one of the
inevitable realities of the future.
Like um,
auto driving cars,
self driving cars are in there.
They seem to be like,
and though,
right?
So yeah,
that's
what ended.
It always feels like human beings are
pushing toward what their version of him
mortality.
Like everybody wants to live forever,
right?
Everybody wants to live forever.
Like germ theory.
Germ theory was a radical theory.
I mean the germ theory remember was it's
a very new concept.
You know,
germ theory was don't drink that water
because there is,
there are germs in there when lave and
hook and vented the microscope and was
checking his own saliva before he
brushed his teeth.
He would like,
he'd look and see there's all this,
did germs in my mouth and they're these
little microbes that were,
that you can't see.
But I created these lenses and you can
see them and then he would clean his
mouth out and he'd spit into the slide
and he'd say,
ah,
there are less of those moving things in
my mouth.
That was the beginning.
And people like that with the beginning
of,
uh,
of the idea that there is something
called bacteria and now we're realizing
there are good bacteria and bad bacteria
and maybe your bile.
But all of these,
all these sorts of developments were
there to push us beyond our biology.
So we didn't have to die of infection
anymore because we came up with this
idea because Alexander Fleming came up
with something called penicillin.
He had a cold and he,
his snot dripped into a petri dish that
had some mold in it.
And he realized that the,
the mold,
it killed the bacteria that was in his
nose.
And he went,
wait a minute,
I'm going to invent something called
penicillin and antibiotics were born.
So we had all these,
all these giant leaps,
this idea that you can't see them but
their germs.
So wash your hands,
what?
And then we'll keep things like the
bubonic plague may be at bay,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so as we move in this direction of
understanding,
of understanding about our own biology,
understanding about our own psychology,
understanding about,
you know,
sort of the dangers of certain
ideologies,
uh,
and,
and why we should embrace other
ideologies.
Like for example,
I don't know everybody's of the same
moral worth because some of these weird
and different because they're gay or
there were weird clothing,
that doesn't mean they should be
ostracized.
In fact,
that means they should be included.
Well,
what are we doing here with all this
knowledge?
What we're doing is we're saying this is
a better way to live.
This is a more comfortable way to live.
This will allow us to live for a longer
period of time in more comfort.
But why?
Why is it so we can come up with better
movies,
books,
ideas?
It starts to get to a point where you're
like,
what are we doing this for?
Like is it just for our entertainment?
And then does that mean that we are
chasing more sensation?
It might be sensory sensation or is the
idea to achieve a higher level of
understanding.
And then there are problems that we
really have trouble with,
which is something like climate change.
Climate change is real.
You've got ice sheets melting at a rate.
You know,
I think what is the,
the Los Angeles basin uses one kilometer
of water a year and Greenland's ice
sheet is melting.
It's something like 240 kilometers.
I mean,
something crazy.
And we're losing,
you know,
sea levels are going to rise.
There's this other huge existential
threat that's going to affect all of us.
Maybe push a half a billion people who
live on coastlines inland to create a
massive amount of,
uh,
you know,
ecological changes on a scale maybe we
haven't seen.
So it's just a very strange thing as we
get closer to learning how to live
together and learning a better life as
we create this neural net where we're
getting a better understanding of what
it's like to be somebody else,
even though their culture,
their software so different,
it makes us more compassionate,
I suppose,
as a group of people.
Right.
We can have a language for it.
We have a,
at least we're trying,
at least we know that's important.
At least we know things like racism,
even though it exists,
is kind of a bad idea for a lot of
reasons.
Yes,
we're getting closer to this goal,
but then I feel like there's this giant
tidal wave behind us,
ecological title women see me and then
what is that?
Honestly,
it's all a moot point.
If we get hit by an asteroid and we have
a lot of near Earth objects that could
fucking,
it's a little in civilization
instantaneously.
It comes back to fractals.
Well,
there's also,
there's that little bomb in Chelsea.
I could have been obliterated.
I got all these plans.
It really does go back to fractals
because one of the mind fuck of all
Mindfox is that when you go into a
person's body,
the deeper you go,
you hit their selves.
You go into their cells,
you find subatomic particles blinking
out of existence,
and most of it is air anyway,
which is a lot like what the fucking
universe.
So we don't,
we don't know because we only have a
limited amount of ability to measure
these things,
but it's entirely possible that inside
every one of those events,
subatomic events where seeing particles
blinking in and out of existence,
you might be able to go deeper and
deeper and deeper and find a whole new
universe.
The human cells,
the university human cells and the
mechanisms as so intricate and so
detailed,
and there's so much going on that it's
actually mind boggling.
You could spend a lifetime studying how
a cell breaks down and what is going on
in a salad.
You could spend a lifetime.
That's the true nature of infinity,
and that's why it's so impossible to
grasp because if there are hundreds of
billions of galaxies in this universe,
each with hundreds of billions of stars,
it's entirely possible that all of that
could just be one subatomic particle
that's in another cell,
that's in some other person in some
other universe.
And that goes on and I mean that is the
true nature of infinity,
that it has no end.
So it is entirely possible that we'll we
look at as a structure.
You look at the inner universe like,
wow,
that's amazing.
Constantly expanding thing.
It's,
it's so beautiful and there's so many
cell,
there's so many stars that it might be a
part of a cell that's in measurable
to our Little Puny La.
Maybe.
Maybe the answer then is surrender like
socrates and Newton to the argue of the
greatest minds that we,
at least in the European tradition,
socrates says,
I know more than everybody else because
I'm very aware of the fact that I
basically know nothing after a lifetime
of contemplation.
And then Newton said,
I'm standing on the shoulders of giants,
but he kind of liked himself to a kid
skipping a rock.
Do you think the surface of the ocean,
that's how much he knows newt was on the
spectrum because it seemed like Newton
had some really weird thing.
You know what he said right at the end
of his life,
his greatest accomplishment.
You know what his greatest
accomplishment.
So funny,
he said,
my greatest accomplishment comp,
he invented calculus,
invented calculus.
It's the spatial relations theory.
Gravity motion.
I mean he's just,
he's the father of all scientists.
Right.
And uh,
he said that he said,
my lifelong,
the,
my biggest achievement was lifelong
celibacy.
Yeah.
That was his thing.
He was into no Posey,
very religious,
very religious.
But whatever that meant.
But yes.
Do I think he was on the spectrum?
I think a mind like that on that level
was on a lot of spectrums.
Well,
what do I know?
But that's another thing,
right?
Isn't it?
When you,
when we measure something or a label,
something like,
oh,
he's got asperger's,
or he's autistic,
you know,
like what,
what are you,
what does that even mean?
Right?
Okay.
It's not like being a white guy,
right?
He's got blue eyes up yet,
but he does,
I see his eyes.
They're blue.
He's the autistic.
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
I see the big gay on his forehead.
No,
you don't.
There's no,
like,
how do you,
what is it?
Just a series of characteristics and
there's a spectrum,
right?
So what,
what level is,
uh,
Einstein that,
you know,
what level is Elon Musk?
At what level are you at,
you know?
Well,
maybe the answer then is to get really
good at one thing.
That's what a lot of people is like.
The Zen sort of,
that's where archery's in,
in the art of archery,
you know,
you,
you learn everything through one thing,
through deep,
deep practice and deep immersion into
one particular discipline.
Because what it requires to be expert
mastery,
like mastery at something will lead you
to a deeper understanding of all things
that that would be the sort of Zen Asian
mindset,
which I've always loved.
I tend to be interested in a fuck load
of things,
but there is something to be said about
Josh Waitzkin,
his book and the art of learning where
he said when he was learning,
he was a chess master and then he got so
into Jujitsu.
Is Marcella Garcia his first black belt?
And he said,
I,
when I was studying Jujitsu,
I was getting better at chess when I was
doing chess,
I was getting better at Jujitsu.
So maybe all of its related.
Well,
I'm sure it is,
but what my point was just so many
people's brains work so differently and
I wonder if that's all just a part of
the mechanism as well is that in order
for this thing to keep moving,
it can't be a bunch of farmers can't
just be what everybody's way humans
interact with each other and the
innovation that comes out of that,
the communication that comes out of
that,
the the change and the influence that
comes out of that,
even things is innocuous.
As a podcast,
she two dudes that sat down,
one of them being a terrorist survivor
yourself maybe,
maybe smoked a little marijuana and just
rambled for two and a half hours.
I heard,
I heard the explosion and saw the smoke.
Yes,
because see,
I think that the,
all of the experiences that we all have,
the good and the bad,
they're influential in some sort of a
strange way and it all seems to be kind
of balancing itself out or at least
pushing into a certain direction and
that direction seems to be the
improvement of the civilization.
Even the like poorly thought out
measures like this woman riding this
awful article about Matt Leblanc.
The idea behind it that she's going to
get support is because she's saying that
someone is doing something even though
it's not true,
someone's doing something bad for
society and culture.
This person has a voice of influence and
they should never work again because
society and culture demands that you
behave a certain way or we will take
away your livelihood.
No more jokes.
Well what the only way that would work
at all other than you're just a mean
person and you're trying to like take
people's jobs away and make people poor.
The only way it would work is if you're
promoting something of merit for the
civilization.
So by saying someone is awful and
terrible and this is why they should
never work again like you were in some
sort of way in your lane minded attempt,
you're trying to push culture forward.
Yes,
and I think that is trying to solve a
problem.
Yeah.
That's a common thread.
Even when we're looking at dealing with
international crisis's.
The reason why we're looking at those
crises is,
is we don't want them to blow up in our
face.
We want to push towards a better future
is dangerous though because this is
where,
um,
principles and understanding and
understanding what the goal is.
Philosophy is very important.
And I'll give you an example.
You gotta be very careful of giving
people a pass and not saying you are,
but of giving people a pass in the
notion that they're trying to solve a
problem because the means don't justify
the ends.
You have plenty of examples.
Uh,
I had an acting teacher one time.
He said,
if you're trying to play Hitler,
you're trying to play Stalin as an
actor.
You can't play him as a monster.
You've got to play him as a guy who's
trying to solve a problem.
You know,
in Hitler's mind,
in his twisted mind,
he was trying to solve a problem.
That problem was Jews,
Gypsies,
gays or anybody who wasn't quote Unquote
Arion.
And he was going to make,
at the end of the day,
he's going to make the world a better
place.
And that's where I think,
and this is where the real work comes
in.
That's where I think it's so important
to be able to articulate for yourself
and for others why,
why certain things are better,
certain ways of living,
certain beliefs,
certain practices.
My God,
Pr,
cultural practice,
certain philosophies politically for
example,
are better for the greater good.
Then is this over here?
And that's where people like Michael
Shermer and Sam Harris are doing great
work.
That's where those guys sit around and
they articulate
for us things that we might intuitively
feel or they sway us in a better
direction when our emotion takes us in a
different direction.
When our emotion says,
let's vote for trump because he's a guy
who at least is quote unquote getting
shit done or he's taken the chess and
the toilet in the air and then the more
sober thinkers who spend time thinking
about this say,
hey bri,
hey joe,
hey steve over there.
Um,
I know you feel this way.
Let me,
let me steer you over here and here's
why.
Because we should be actually,
it's not just about trying to solve the
problem,
but let,
let's,
let's get to what we're really trying to
get to and here's what,
there's also a lot going on.
We're like we talked about before,
people love to be on a team.
They love to associate with a group.
We all do,
and that's why they were in that ugly
hat.
That red hat with the white letters,
keep ms,
make America great again,
and that's not,
that's a,
that's a fuck you to everyone is
looking,
it's a bread feather.
It's on your,
a bright red peacock feather that's on
your head and you're,
it's,
you're also like other assholes,
fellow assholes.
You see them and they honk at you and
they'll like make America great gun Bro.
And they'll pump their fist up.
I mean,
this is a part of what's going on here.
It's not just a bunch of people that are
like,
look,
this system is fucked.
The only way it's going to be fixed is
if it just,
the whole thing gets thrown into
turmoil.
He's our best bet for that and I would
agree.
He's our best bet for that.
He just is,
is as far as like upsetting the tray and
like going,
okay,
let's see what happens now.
Well let's,
let's,
let's fix some shit.
Obviously.
How'd that guy get through?
Yeah,
like he's our best bet for that,
but man,
it's,
it's dangerous.
It's dangerous.
It's dangerous to to also cater to that
lowest common denominator
earned in revolutions,
revolutions an even no matter how small,
the idea that you're going to take,
everything that's sort of settled,
it was there for a reason that sort of
became theirs.
There is an organic set point sometimes
to societies and when you come in and
somebody just throws everything out with
the bath water,
it does historically have a good,
it typically doesn't have a good day.
Does that mean maybe you can maybe can't
be,
it's possible they could engineer
correctly,
but the,
the,
the real issue is he doesn't like as a
spokesperson,
he doesn't represent progress.
No.
Like Obama represented substantial
progress over Bush as far as speaking as
far as his intelligence level has
articulation level.
His likeability is in that.
I would even argue his also,
his prudence is an inaction is he was
very careful.
He,
a lot of what we'll define Obama's
presidency I think,
and probably in a favorable light,
is,
is the fact that he was not willing to
take action very often,
which is just as important sometimes as
taking action.
Do you think it's possible he could free
Edward Snowden?
The could exonerate him before he leaves
office?
I take heat for this,
but personally I hope,
I
hope he does.
Pardon him.
You got to take heat from that.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
a lot of people consider him a trader
and I think,
uh,
you know,
you hear a lot of this,
but I think Edward Snowden did us a
great service.
I think he's a very gutsy guy.
He's a very,
he's an American of a patriot.
I agree with it.
He was alerting us of a crime that
people that we elected,
we're engaging in and a lot of people
that we didn't elect a lot of people
that we're doing something that's
unconstitutional,
that's not approved and that the
citizens of the United States do not
want.
But that's a good example of emotion.
Right?
That's a good example of people that get
very emotional at the idea that this guy
betrayed our intelligence agency,
our military and things like that.
So that's what they're saying.
So that becomes team,
you know,
Bill,
look at it in this perspective.
They caught that fucking guy in New
York,
the book the bomber within a couple of
days.
Would they have been able to do that if
they did not have extensive surveillance
methods?
That's a good question.
And is that worth the influence that
these these surveillance methods have on
us?
Like if you know that your phone's being
watched and that all those Dick pictures
that you send are all being collected
somewhere and then all those crazy texts
you sent about the government
conspiracies are all being collected
somewhere and potentially could be used
against you if you run for office
somewhere.
So if you decide to run for office and
he said,
you know what,
you know I love New York City is time.
New York City had a mayor that the
people understand I'm going to run for
years.
I know I'm just an actor,
but I want to.
And then all of sudden they pull you
into a room and say,
Hey Brian,
come over here.
We just,
we'd like to talk to you about some of
the emails that you've sent over the
years.
I'll,
I'll answer that question with two with
two parts.
What does this one,
sorry.
There's a new radio lab that's talking
about surveillance.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Crazy stories in it.
And they've done good stuff in that
Scott lab where they caught where they
caught the cartel members and stuff.
But I'll answer that two ways.
One is if,
if surveillance is a reality and law
enforcement has to have some sort of
surveillance,
they do great work and they keep us
safe.
However,
there are their history would suggest
two things.
One is that uh,
surveillance,
if you give the government power over
you in that context,
it's only going to grow unless you have
very strong checks,
balances and transparency.
It is only going to grow.
And that has been the track record of
every government and that's just how
human beings are.
They are going to take the power they
feel is necessary and more so if you
give it to them.
So he was eisenhower leaving office that
the military industrial complex,
that crazy speech that he gave,
which was just like whoa.
It was precious.
It wasn't,
it was so amazing because it was only
seen on television that one time and
then it took until it was made into vhs
or DVD or whatever and then leaked
online where people got a glimpse.
I mean most people are not going over
former presidential speeches with a fine
tooth comb trying to find nuggets of
wisdom.
But that one now has made its way into
the cultural zeitgeist.
Sure.
Outcome.
This really important.
You know,
it was a,
it was a call,
it was called to the people.
He's saying,
be careful because there's a machine out
there that wants to go to war.
Well,
be careful of this to the second part to
the idea that surveillance and uh,
is,
you know,
shouldn't be checked and Edward Snowden
should be,
is a trader.
Well,
well the fact is is that if the
government now has control over what I
say and if the government is listening
in without my consent and I'm a private
citizen who doesn't commit crimes,
then I'm sorry,
but the terrorists have won.
They won because they changed the way I
think and they changed the way my
governor governs me and they have
created anonymity and a power structure
that can do whatever the fuck they want
to its citizenry.
That is UNAMERICAN,
that is anti-constitutional.
That is not the country I want to live
in.
It's not most importantly what makes
this country great.
It is the opposite.
It is what Russia does and a lot of
other countries,
so if you want a weaker country,
ironically it is not to give government
agencies,
I don't care who they are,
I don't care how well intentioned they
are and a lot of them are well
intentioned,
they do great work and they keep us
safe.
You better have transparency and you
have better have checks and balances and
you better be following the law and you
better have court orders,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I want all those systems in place.
I want,
I'm in my,
and you know what,
it might be cumbersome,
might be a pain in the ass.
It might even make us a little less safe
sometimes,
but I'll take it.
I'll fucking take that over.
Giving any government agency power over
my private affairs and letting them
listen in specifically.
And then ultimately,
at the end of the day,
a big part of the problem is that
they're all just people like you,
really curious.
They're just people.
You can really can't have people having
that kind of control and power over
other people.
Just as we talked about at the beginning
of the podcast,
that starts out about Greenpeace and
then after a,
it becomes about having power.
I mean,
people love to have a position of
influence and power and they don't give
it up.
Use it.
Yeah.
When,
if that is your life,
I mean,
that is what you do.
I'm a cop.
I'm a police officer and I'm the law in
this town.
I mean,
Pete,
we love those movies.
Um,
the law,
you know,
that kind of craziness is,
it's,
it's human toxic hating.
People always say,
oh the cops and said like,
look,
there are a lot of great,
like we said.
I mean they were,
were people is people stop saying,
yeah,
it's just people.
So what's the solution?
How do you,
how do you,
I mean the solution was fee.
Well the solution,
if you,
if you read the constitution,
you start with the federalist papers and
read the Constitution and the bill of
rights,
that's the solution.
That's what makes our country great.
Again.
I know I get,
so I'm,
I'm and I like to like,
I like to point this out and that that
is,
they solve the political,
if our
founding fathers that that's,
that's the solution.
Yes.
New Challenges.
This is complicated men.
Yes,
we do need surveillance.
technology is making it so that they can
listen in on all that,
but it's also making them transparent.
They're getting dusted left and right as
people from our generation are slowly
starting to get into office.
And there's,
there's more of that to people who grew
up and have the internet when they were
younger and it helped form their,
their understanding of the world in a
better way.
And it also explained to them the nature
of transparency.
Like you're seeing this guy who was a
hillary Clinton's email deleter they
found his account on reddit and he was
asking a couple of years ago how to
delete emails,
chains,
mass.
Yeah.
I mean it's total smoking gun.
Damn.
They found it and then he deleted the
reddit post after they found it because
he had had a certain reddit handle and
they could see,
they could bring that reddit handle,
they could connect it back to him.
Yeah.
That a lot of that I suspect is,
is,
is hillary not wanting people to see
that.
She was talking about how this was an
Islamic fundamentalist movement that
began Bengazi stuff.
Like there's a lot,
you know,
that they,
the Obama administration has this
strange edict and where they don't
really mention that it's Islamic
terrorism.
They mentioned that it's extremism.
Well,
how about Orlando?
They literally cut it out of the
transcripts.
The things that the shooter was saying,
they'd cut mentions to Islam and
[inaudible] were living.
So we live in where,
yeah,
you're lying.
That's not helping anybody not helping
any.
The fact of the matter is these people
are Islamic fundamentalists and you're
just gonna make things worse.
If you don't acknowledge that fact,
you're just going to deny people
information.
They're going to think there's some sort
of conspiracy.
They're going to get angry.
They're going to feel like they're not
being represented properly.
They're going to think these liberal
pussies are fucking ruining our great
country,
and it's going to build up Donald Trump.
That's where a guy like Donald Trump
comes from.
The over the over sensitivity of the
left is what's created Donald Trump.
The acceptance of Caitlyn Jenner created
Donald Trump.
This is Caitlyn Jenner is the prime.
If you got to go back to Caitlyn Jenner,
you gotta go back to Bruce Jenner first,
right?
And that goes just tiny,
tiny little nose.
He got,
well,
how about the jaw?
He goes,
jaw shave down.
He's such a good looking man and is
facing a rubber,
you know,
its face doesn't move.
He can't talk.
Right.
It's crazy.
And we're supposed to ignore the fact
that he irresponsibly plowed into a
woman and pushed her into fucking
traffic and killed her.
Was he on his phone?
It was not paying attention.
He rear ended with a truck,
a giant escalate that was pulling a
boat.
So he had all this weight,
right.
He slams in this woman's car,
pushes her into traffic and she gets hit
by an oncoming car and you know,
we're supposed to be like,
listen,
diversity is what's important here and
not a woman's life.
What's important here?
The My,
exactly.
Anyways,
it just drops it.
Everybody drops an exonerates him.
And I'm not saying she should be
punished forever being careless,
but I'm saying that's a significant
indicator of someone having a fucked up
personality that all you want to do and
these these talks,
you talking
about gender and yourself,
you fucking killed somebody in traffic,
man.
You should be,
you should be talking about that life
changing moment all the time.
And I say,
man,
you know,
like dude,
like you could say,
Hey guy,
you can't say that to a girl.
Kenya,
she killed someone.
Fucking God damn it.
I'm tired of doing that.
I'm tired of this.
He,
she switcheroo well I haven't.
You got one for life.
You'll fuck wait,
what a bank.
Well,
can I ask you a question?
You're 30 you have to make a choice,
right?
Hey,
what are you in Guinea Pool?
You could be whatever the fuck you want
up until 30 once you hit 30 you got to
shit or get off the pot.
Who are you?
Can I,
what is his dwarf?
Tiny people is midget dwarf.
Both of those are bad words.
I can't just say dwarfing.
The seven dwarfs.
Midget.
You can't say dwarf ism is an actual
disease.
So I can't call someone a dwarf.
I think they all prefer a little people.
You know?
Again,
we have too many fucking labels.
There's too many labels attached to
anything.
A jail.
Don't do it.
Don't do dwarf jokes.
Handsome and tall,
and you have white privilege.
I don't want to make fun of anybody
who's anybody.
I don't,
I,
I never shop on that.
It's important to make fun of people.
They need to know the ridiculous,
but only if it's like their behavior.
Yes.
You know,
south their genetics and especially not
dwarfism.
That's a motherfucker,
you know,
I'm only like a foot away from poor
fism.
There's several people that are foot
taller than me.
I'm five,
eight to six foot eight.
A lot of people out there,
if I was a foot shorter,
yeah,
I'm a dwarf.
I walk around with Brennan Shop.
I feel like a doorframe.
No,
and I feel like an old guy and you know,
it hurts my feelings because women look
at him and I could be a cup of coffee a
lot of times.
A Cup of coffee's nice.
It'll be a spore.
I like a cup of coffee.
I'm like a mushroom.
He's holding.
I'm like a potted plant.
He's holding it.
He's walking down and they could give a
fuck about the potted plant tape.
Folks would be kind of cute.
It says a cup.
Let it go.
Tait Fletcher says a cup of coffee's
like a warm hug.
You're going to let it go.
Look,
there's a lot of people that never got
to be handsome.
God,
you're handsome for a long time.
I sure it was.
I'm still kind of all right.
You're all right.
I mean,
look it,
man.
You're funny.
You're funny guy.
I got a great mind.
He went to him.
Yeah,
you're really fun to hang out.
I like going camping with you.
Uh,
we got to do another hunting trip,
dude.
We do last one.
Last one was bull ring.
I haven't shot,
my vote wasn't boring.
I had a great time,
but not as good.
Come on,
man.
Gotta I gotta bring you,
but you've got to learn how to shoot a
bow and Arrow or we'll have to go use
it.
We'll use rifles.
How about this?
How about next hunting trip?
I'll go with you and I won't even shoot
anything because last couple of them
you've been unsuccessful.
I'll go and just be your backup.
Listen,
we are your ammunition corridor.
I'll be a porter.
I would like to,
I like the whole day.
A umbrella would be entire show,
like P diddy's assistant.
I would be a fun,
that would be a fun show if fantastic.
My Book Cook Cause it would make us some
tea,
some tea and biscuits.
It's four o'clock in the afternoon and
it would be fair because I shot that
Turkey and then you got nothing,
you know.
And we before that we just got skunked
on that island.
Outrageous.
It's soaking wet for six days.
And Ella,
let's go.
We needed another a hunting trail.
I love doing them.
Let's do it.
Alright,
I'm bringing on James Kingston.
Now we're going to do another podcast
and a couple of minutes.
You gonna stick around for a few minutes
to talk to this guy.
He's got to run.
Daddy's got to go.
James Kingston,
who's the guy who's crazy gets on top of
buildings,
was Gopros and shit makes you shit your
pants.
He's on his way.
Brian can come see me at the auto focus
of nature.
You're an American tradition and
American comedian,
Ottawa,
algonquin.
September 30th one of God's gifts.
Go see him.
God Damn hilarious.
Okay.